and we are back here on on all platforms
wherever you're tuning in
twitch or YouTube or chest comm directly
thanks for thanks for hanging with us
they're a bit of a bit of a crashing
they're of our of our of our software
but we are we are back and ready to roll
we still have world champion Vichy and
on here as well as video Gujarati and
you guys were you guys were telling
stories but now we can get back into it
continue wherever wherever you were
talking about
yeah well what I was saying when
restrictions are increasing slightly in
Germany but given what I was doing
anyway before and now I haven't actually
had to change my behavior too much so
even before the restrictions I wasn't
meeting a lot of people and so on before
the restrictions manageable you were
looking at a lot of chess and with the
restrictions you're still looking at a
lot of chess so I guess some things
don't change huh haven't been going out
much and I'm happy to get a chance to go
for a run in the morning and that's it
after that I pretty much take like up
and little grocery shopping and that's
it makes sense
my eyes keep going back to this NBL jana
palmistry game and sorry to just be all
over the place here but Yohn still
hasn't moved and I wanted to ask you
both I guess we can start with you vidit
are you getting concerned for yawn or do
you think he still has things under
control because the position to me is
very unclear in terms of how black is
going to get his pieces out especially
at work on g8 so with the time man who
likes it start with you've in it
what are your thoughts about this
position and for Yuans time usage as I
said previously the next two three moves
are really important like if you can get
Knight b6 you'll be completely fine but
it's not so easy to do that and I guess
that's what is figuring out because it's
very easy to go wrong as well so what's
what's the one you're thinking of that
video is black playing Knight b6 right
away no no I mean like the line which
you checked right one will be one and
you can't go 96 because of c4 right so I
was thinking something like Queenie six
instead of Knight b6
but then c5 is not protected so I'm also
unsure but this at least stops castle
this looks like a good way but you know
you kind of give up the B file
at least I could not see how to proceed
with wide-eyed because they wouldn't be
one Queen Essex it's good thoughts here
well rook takes be one queen bee 196 is
it so clear it because see for my go
quit takes a three rook 83 we're looking
at yeah and then I go Queenie six PC by
97 but it looks wobbly
a milder feeling he's not really going
to charge into this race if I hear maybe
I can make sleep over there Quincy
because the biggest once a play like
this repeat 3 here is a rupee three
comes in
but then I could in theory sack played
knight c6 allow you to I even this wing
yeah maybe maybe here are some g5
a g16 g17 spectacular it looks pretty
suspicious though right
yeah and I yeah
okay
yeah so we're not we're not thinking
this night be six line then we're
thinking but first of all you know NBC
61 Queen b6 okay that should be one
thing then maybe way to just play queen
d3 and try to get in
when the cellist will be three right
on this 26
[Music]
well can I just castle and even get rid
of my a pawn like how how worried should
I be about whatever you're doing on the
Queen sir okay so castles if C d-four I
go to be one and then
yeah I like white
[Music]
well and I was gonna back up for a
second obviously these variations are
being calculated by the players but just
from a practical point of view Vichy
obviously you've played you played neppo
before when he goes into this kind of
thinking and this is maybe the longest
the longest stud
I guess think we've seen him taking the
entire tournament right I mean we know
he's a guy that plays very fast when
he's confident and knows what he's doing
so is there any kind of practical
psychological stuff that you would that
she would talk about here with neppo
actually really slowing down here and
then not not being quite sure what to do
well the thing is you may see a position
like similar similar position to this
and you'll get a general sense of what
you think I you like the position or not
but as a board you suddenly flipping to
a different frame of mind where you
actually have to decide what you get to
play next as opposed to liking the
position in general right and the same
is that the computer may not have been
very worried but it's but at this point
suddenly you have to stop thinking of
specific moves you want to make so I
think it's certainly worth investing
some time here because it's easy to get
a decision wrong but personally I think
blacc should be doing ok the big problem
for ISM remains how to get the king and
rook sorted but maybe rupee one could be
one Queen a6 is a decent way to play
because it doesn't allow white to castle
and that's important because a white can
castle and g4 that's an plaza maybe what
white should then continue with g4 and
try to go at four
well I mean maybe it'll catch three f3
to keep probing on f7 but it's actually
very hard to make that work so you need
a queen on g4 before that becomes very
effective so yeah and I was thinking of
castling by hand with f3 king of two but
the problem with that is then you look
can ever come to have three so you kind
of force wise hand into making a really
specific decision there and if you're
gonna castle by hand then you don't get
that attack at least the one that you
want so I think you're right that the
Queen on a6 is really pester something
did it was matching that move a long
time ago and it's becoming more annoying
for me to deal with because my instinct
is like I like White's position but the
longer this game continues the life
Square is filled very soft for white and
black and expose them yes I also think
there's some quite some value to keeping
that King tied down for now but I mean I
can't really see that I want to play h3
f3 I think much more likely I would like
to make g4 work and therefore
potentially
well obviously on trying to come up with
the critical line taking his time and
speaking of taking his time sorry I went
to clicked on the wrong board but a nice
giri has been thinking here for quite
quite a minute after Queen to g4 Grichuk
has has not only dealt it seems with
Gary's novelty with 93 but late this age
five and kind of creative queen d4 queen
g4 idea seems to be doing okay here yeah
Queen D feels a great move and you know
I was not going to make fun of an ish
but now that even with it tucked in I
think the likelihood of Bishop f3 g2 is
going up you guys to make fun of any
show you want the problem I make a habit
of it on this show so the well it jokes
aside I mean what is why play for here
Queen d4 who you more very creative
cleany one but Bishop e6 and I can't
really see the point of my play or maybe
like this Queen e1 and then h3 here
move the queen and then go 94 and that
way again mere tickle the bishop but
after Queen e1 h for a sentinel and then
whites awkwardly placed to take
advantage or anything
so Queenie one hitch for
edge for a bit more so what line play
actually here
during the Queenie six raise a year idea
six nights a little bit unpleasant but
maybe g6 and then take on g4
I don't you think it looks though this
you've clearly been doing too much
coming sacrificing pieces like they're
not yours
yes exactly but I think it works here
this looks pretty good for black gh3
yeah yeah yeah this is this actually
just looks like it's almost crushing
this Bishop takes chief for you should
be 4f check well I find that I
call Bishop f3 f g4 Bishop yeah and I
think a full check you arranged the king
somewhere
and then you go h5 f5 sorry Jerome yeah
but I can't say I like I'm liking the
way this is going yeah maybe black
should just take on g4 first yeah maybe
well the problem h4 is I think h3
geforce quite desirable for white in
many ways
and if I don't play h4 then how to go
about things
maybe Queenie ones not so bad actually
but well Queenie one I liked your line
that you were making with the how did
instead of h4 how do you say Leo and
Bishop e6 said of age 4 yeah at that
hedge 3 yeah and then the Queen g6 94
was 95
hmm okay against d3
I'm just trying to get castle and be
safe could I be do I get might take six
Toph oh I mean you could get messy I
mean you can go king of fake bishop a
bishop x3 or something I don't know but
yeah this isn't exactly my type of
commentary position because not my
pieces happy to sacrifice these
exchanges it looks really dangerous you
know I'm into it I mean I'm loving it
and I agree with you Robert the more we
have Vichy on the more he the more he
sacrifices this is great but ok let's
let's go back to the game between Vashti
the Grove and DiPalma Nietzsche because
c4 has been played definitely not not
the approach any of us were advocating
for advocating for excuse me I can't
talk today because it seemed one of the
key ideas the computer liked as early as
when vidit suggested it many many
minutes ago is to bring the Queen to a6
holding the light squares makes White's
life a little dysfunctional so c4 is
kind of the opposite of that you're
actually closing that diagonal and
allowing light to castle are we
surprised by this move from that both
I am surprised yes and now you can get
this fish's idea the castle f/4g fall
you know it will be really strong if it
happens like six and Keeney seven areas
hmm but still I like my therefore in
fact I can I can start with therefore
and maybe sometimes I get lucky and get
f5 without having to play q4 and then I
play g4 if I have to
well is there also something to be said
for her castle castle because if I play
after castling if I go F orange e4 black
be able to play Jacek somewhere well if
I just start off with g4 let me prepare
it let me go d4 an f4 here
unless like it's going to go Queen takes
a three here Queen it will not be three
but here is a one room takes a seven and
I'm happy because also this bishop see
183 in the air okay you'll go King e8
and then you'll try to kick my rook
around with knight c6
am I just a bit slow on the inside
I mean if you can go in Queen
Queen B Phi
and is the combination so bad even if it
happens
well the question is is my rook
sustainable there number seven it is
right let's say awesome here maybe
already it's time for f3 King at - okay
but let's try castles if I take on a
forum play knight c6 already Europe
isn't coming back to the 7th any times
yeah and with you know no sitting with
no separation between the pawn structure
it feels like what chances are not quite
as good because I think somehow having
planned both sides the board feels
necessary excuse me for whites chances
here and I don't know I just want a
castle instead of playing g4 first I
just want a castle I don't okay like I
don't know exactly how blacks gonna
unravel cuz you said nice e16 e7 but I
sort of want to play like Queen c2 and
maybe even Queen h7 myself at some point
or f4 f5 of course is still the idea
because if my c6 then I can play of
foreign and threatening f5 without
having to need you for half so maybe
castles is just better because if Queen
takes a three then we want to have
something specific on that side
yeah just to unpack that idea for
everyone watching the key point is Vichy
is throwing an F for the moment nice e6
comes in because the night is relieving
its pressure here you don't want to play
it for too early in a lot of positions
where you block your own bishops gaze
because maybe that allows black to kind
of untie maybe with the Jeep on we like
castles first as like kind of a flexible
move here
sure and if castles queen III I think
Roque one if Queen b3 I'm just going to
go Quincy one I mean I don't think they
pons very relevant but anything I can do
in the king size will be let's a play
Mike c6 year you still go for right
think so and if they're forward I play
f5
I'm just gonna break the whole board
open right you're daring me to so I'm
gonna do it okay G follow
yeah chief 187 no no in that position
again
so after in the line we were looking at
with castles queen a3
yeah and now Nexus except for two five
or something
so f4 here yeah and black plays that
further thing ah can I even take any
take and glare father
yeah exactly
yeah kind of the first thing I was
thinking about and of course Vidhan
mission you can correct me if I was
wrong I just kept harping on this rook
on g8 is really bothering me that I
didn't see a clear way to get that rook
over to the Queen side and actually your
kid is Knight c67 idea I was thinking
about that before playing Queen a5 and
ibc for I just didn't like and I think
none of us liked that move for black as
he played it but I was thinking it with
the Queen on c7 just trying to go 90 67
and then go from G to b8 a long time ago
it might have been slow but it just felt
like that rook cannot last on g8 for too
much longer as white will build up the
pressure just down of rook chat tuning
in saying it looks like America versus
India and a match this were American
versus India India wins this match every
time so this is not a match that Robert
Hess and I are willingly taking on the
even with video'd apparently no don't
you see in one minute live chess with
Maxine's maybe bullet maybe bullet we'd
have a chance yeah
giant oh by the way you're welcome we
can play that next time I know you've
watched me and Maxine the last couple
years I know you want that you want to
get that early morning exercise we can
throw down next time
probably something like swordplay chests
also write some some kind of stuff yeah
we do have four players chests yeah
anyway well let's take our bird's-eye
view we'll take a second to step back
remind everybody that all four games of
course are still in progress here in
round seven of the Fida candidates
tournament we have the biggest matchup
on the big board there where we've been
focused for the most of the time
Maxine voce the Grob versus no Jana pom
Nishi and it's been an interesting one
we've got a Petroff there between
Caruana and Wang Hao looks like it's
moving along we can we can stay here and
keep an eye on all four games and kind
of rotate through the big board here
what are our thoughts on these last few
moves that have happened
Fabiano play d4 d5 and now this uh this
line with g5 has come on as his coming
so what do you think about the way
fabi's playing this position here does
she
I don't know
you know lash out I could play a fire
against
not your pieces you're allowed to lash
out f5g f6 Knight f6
books who's playing for an advantage
here because a few movies go
we all thought wow maybe slightly better
but what do you think now even before f5
it feels to me that black can't start
thinking about being ambitious well how
did win that nice game and run one over
Bingley red with the black piece isn't
outplayed I think ok that was much more
manual position in many ways than this
one but they didn't Vichy what are you
guys thinking in this position should
one how think with some ambition
especially cuz I had on the clock
I don't if black can be but that's good
like my hoping
[Music]
yeah there should be I agree I don't
think black is better here but sometimes
you in the process of making good moves
things like f5 and all the game can turn
so reminds me of a night off a little
bit when these positions where white has
upon and g5 and s trainee for black
plays x-files and suddenly f3 turns out
to be because something I don't know
right but so far of course it's not
enough to
be significant but well if not if I what
else am I going to do g6 and 90 76 or
something maybe g6
and then just plain IG 7 f5 MIG so many
things but data awesome Knight f6 died
well I live with that
maybe you could even take only for at
some point but ya give suspicious
well if I'm gonna take on e4 I probably
want you to take back with the I'm not
sure which one is worse Shh
I think I want to avoid taking on e4 as
long as possible because both Fe 475 as
well as Bishop b4 Rambla for enhanced
I mean I like this idea with Knight g7
to either East six rat at 5 and the
problem for white is you would love to
put your Bishop on c3 rather than on e3
but as soon as you do that then I take
on e4 because g5 is hanging so it seems
like White has to figure things out here
as well it's not just possible to
execute your plan um maybe I'm still
like a fighter I still like exactly yeah
I'm merely a fight yeah it's a cheerful
oops normal well you're kind of happy
right because if you move the knight of
Phrygia first of all I can't believe we
should pay except 6 because if f3 is
that's likely wobbly and I don't see why
I can't take it like this it might have
six uh play Knight f6 and and and now
it's becoming very night or fish in in
your idea that that's kind of a common
counter strike against the English
attack structure and white is strapped
with the weakest pawn on the board here
yeah maybe to e5 or something suddenly
is blunting that bishop very well so
you'd apply the bishop on e3 lacks d4
and start punching against anything
there so that's going to be
I languish like six eight children I
wasn't I wasn't sure at five was as good
as we would normally see in those
English attacks but Bishop takes f6 I
think it's really key kind of keeping
the knight on the edge of the board here
and and holding the a Foursquare this is
all looking very hard for white to
unwind and deal with this weakness okay
what a white plays Knight g5 here after
Bishop f6
hmm
g6 just g6
yeah looks like
h4 you said C fever before sorry okay
miss your website a can I go Bishop b4
and okay you'll be sorry is there reason
this is the reason you can't take on g5
and take on f3
um not particularly if a bishop takes d8
takes f3 and and maybe I'm going to have
to settle for me
I don't know Bishop g5 bishop moves
Bishop h6 mighty now actually black get
done turn out to be better you know
right
or maybe yeah I can't say that it was
impossible maybe hit six then you go
night at seven
yeah I didn't make marriage seven
logistics is good no d6 I don't know can
i play
I mean why couldn't you just take care
should be equal in these positions
there's no okay this doesn't work this
bishops in it okay yeah but you want to
wait for c4
so you have to wait for c4 that's the
key
I like black eye I'm not saying of
course that it's better for black eye I
don't believe it is objectively but the
way this game is going it feels like
Fabiano's never felt comfortable and
both both of you to that admission
you've said that I mean playing against
your own main line is very uncomfortable
and to me it feels like Fabiano I was
trying to try to get a win out of
nothing each other like wish for a win
whereas he's compromised his kingside
structure he's create some weaknesses
very long-term weaknesses and black has
this critical moment here to clarify
matters with f5 and get a trade or
played g6 97 a slower methodical
rerouting approach but I don't feel like
Fabio knows that comfortable in this
game I don't think he's attained what he
wants but
I'm just curious by the way they cast as
5gf what's wrong with Knight f6 because
cousin Bishop I just not a specialist
that's all no Bishop f6 is probably a
better move but I could not say
immediately be sure six is more dynamic
I think can we go for this right here
then five anywhere but in addition 456
Knight g5 maybe no yeah it's six and
then hit six
you can I drop my bishop back somewhere
like bishop well in that case I could
even play he5 Bishop f3 and g4 yeah but
I kinda wanted if you go Bishop c1 and I
go
Danny's trying to play c4 after age six
Vichy that's what I love I know it
probably doesn't work but I want to get
rid of the light squares
I have 96
maybe it actually works because if takes
you take and the pawn is a little bit
comfortable but hang on a second and can
you play Bishop d7 96 Bishop f3 or s but
then just do okay and 98 is gonna be
unpleasant
I don't do 294 sorry but you can take on
d8 Bishop takes D 1 instead of root D 2
you can take on da yeah whether you have
nice c6 right and then above and how do
you evaluate that I mean okay well why
only y can be better in those lines but
even there I felt like black so chances
to maybe hold that position right with
after c4 you know this is line Bishop d7
the exactly the one you're looking at
then c4 can I go Bishop f7 probably and
I guess now but now you can go Bishop c1
right
it's sick I'm kind of hoping that I know
this will be six a common idea here so
probably just take one at seven and
something like given King c2 or Bishop a
baby comes and gives a check on g6 nice
right
okay well I mean
feeling a little bit desperate or it
seems that fish not vichy Fabiano is I
was implying maybe earlier just the g4
was kind of a sign of how he's feeling
about the tournament I mean he doesn't
want to doesn't want to settle here
maybe he wants to play for more than
just a half point here is white but
we're definitely in agreement that it's
double edged and maybe I think I think
this Bishop takes f6 was clear enough to
say that black is in just a totally fine
position here by do I see that Alisha's
Saudi Benitez has disappointed us no he
has disappointed us we're not making a
draw that's why not chasing a draw he's
made a Queen trade and the game is on
it's a needle a draw for you know the
the jokes Indonesia's expense never get
old I don't know why they just never get
old all right but seriously Grichuk did
handle anisha's novelty well and the
Queen trade means that black is I'll be
totally equal here more than fine
[Music]
not sure where we think this game is
going to go but
well let me ask you Vidhan and Vichy
which side would you take here white or
black
right while I think is equal this of
this equality right which side would you
prefer to play on I'm half this time -
the same way except Bishop g4 is very
unpleasant because I'd rather play look
if you want decide d1 okay he's gone
true T - yeah then black plays route d8
or you can even go long cross but me and
don't there's a little bit suspicious
no why
if I go d4 you'll play 197 all night
before I don't know by the way you come
to blockading this isolated pawn maybe
on d5
well night before I want to take take
and go Bishop e5 or Bishop g5 and claim
that I'm doubling your pawns for I don't
see I don't see something huge anyway
I once again prefer the black side of a
Louisville position
yes actually reasonable because my
pieces are coming somewhere there pretty
fast
well the the game's continuing all four
of them and I think that commentary is
more than reasonable we appreciate what
staying with us but we're gonna take a
very very quick break
when we return more coverage here of
round seven of the 20/20 feet eight
candidates tournament huge games still
going vache the grove 'nope on me she's
still still on on the on the think here
no it's mb else think but we'll be right
back when we do we may may or may not
still have our guest with us but either
way don't go anywhere
plenty more ahead in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
you
and we are back here yet again the
coverage of the 2020 feat a candidates
tournament continues for everyone and
our daily question if you haven't have
missed it is is asked because of the
tournament situation and we posed the
question to ourselves often Robert and
and the team and I do that as we are
kind of preparing for this and a
national question came up is is this a
must-win situation already for Maxine
bhashya the grove and if so how do you
mentally prepare for that use the hash
tag feed a candidates get involved maybe
make your own comparisons to other
sports and your other thoughts on must
wins and that that term can be kind of
loose Robert technically nothing is a
must-win until it's a must-win but if we
look at the the stats of these two guys
and all that all the prep we did here
coming into it it felt very must-win ish
for MBL did it not well it's really hard
to say because as many players note
about Jana Palma she he's there a
streaky player so far we've seen the
great beyond not the good young the
great yard
he has been unbelievable with plus three
in the first six games but you never
know how things are going to go down the
stretch for him as he started three out
of three in the Sinquefield Cup in 2019
if I'm not mistaken so you know it was
the Zagreb was one of the grad chest
tour events I'm not remembering exactly
which one but it was definitely up
cuz he lost a fishing around one in them
so yeah it remains to be seen but I do
feel like for MDL considering his place
before this round he needed the win if
he wants to be the winner of the
tournament
I think if other people want to win it
wasn't a must-win you know they don't
have to take Yan down just yet but for
Maxime as he hopes to contempt the world
championship he needs this victory well
and indeed he does doing so would would
tie the standings and and also kind of
bring everybody else back into the fold
- it's kind of a weird situation by
winning this game Maxime vache the Groff
would not only be sharing the
leaderboard atop the leaderboard but
also it would it would shorten the gap
between dion neppo and the rest of field
so we've had a couple moves here since
we left it rook to b6 played followed by
Queens
- so what's interesting again that the
questionable decision we had a few moves
ago was the computer suggestion along
with Vishy Anand video Gujarati who've
been awesome and thanks for being with
us watching them was Queen a six the
idea is to keep the pressure on the
light squares and and make it difficult
for white as far as knowing knowing how
to handle the pressure of the Queen but
instead Yan does just the opposite
playing c4 which closes the structure
and and I guess kind of secure is why
it's gonna have an edge for a while
castles is met by Brooke b6 that that's
a good move I think for black you're
just saying hey if you take I'm taking
with the night and making it very easy
for me to continue to bring pressure
over here to the Queen side but mvl just
plays Queen c2 he's connecting the rooks
and kind of reminding black Robert that
he's sort of playing down a rook as
vichy said what are your thoughts on
where this game is going and why you
like White's chances White's plan is far
easier spot F for g4 f5 we've been
talking about this we'll continue
talking about it and what is blacks plan
if you play the he just played okay I
just pressed them return to game button
in Brooke a chase on the board so he
must have just played for catch it he
played a rookie in shape two reasons why
he did it one is now Queen age seven is
never possible and then move Queen age
seven looks ridiculous at first glance
but it keeps black totally tied down
remember one idea we keep mentioning is
knight c6 c7 but if that white Queen
were on h7 you wouldn't be able to get
your King out to e7 so it takes away the
h7 square which in turn protects g7 you
also give yourself the opportunity to
play g6 because you couldn't play g6
with that h6 pawn being so weak but with
the rook on h8 at some moment you can
play g6 and the third reason and perhaps
the reason that Yan did this is he might
play King g8 and then I was a king h7
but you can't get King h7 I wanted to
like to somehow go King g8 like go King
h7 them room I've rook over but with the
Queen already on c2 I'm just not seeing
that happening so change ad not a real
plan because Knight if I was always
kicked out with g4 that moves two
options
for the rationale behind the movement I
still think that white can play very
straightforward way you know play for f4
g4 or play eight for Bishop c1 bishop a3
at the right moment and get that Bishop
on to its best diagonal we love that
French idea it's something we constantly
call - it's white taking advantage
flexing if you will that he's the only
one with the dark square bishop and by
the way on that note Maxime doesn't need
to be asked twice Robert he also loves
your idea he's been taking lessons from
you recently right you can tell people
Maxime well Maxime it we had a fun time
in New York as I mentioned in previous
broadcast he had never walked across the
Brooklyn Bridge I was like hey we got to
do that we had breakfast with Alexandra
boats has three of us and to walk across
the Brooklyn Bridge a great time and you
know I would like to think that I he was
in good spirits based on his vacation
you weren't even know why he was in good
spirits because at the time he had no
idea that he was headed back home but
with a chance to get into the candidates
tournament came over Java off
withdrawing due to due to concerns about
Koba 19 justifiably so and the
coronavirus but but Maxime was not gonna
say no when destiny when fate comes
calling you opened the door as they say
and if Maxie wins this game and ties
ties to nepo atop the leaderboard
wouldn't that be something
right last-minute last-minute
replacement with the least preparation
possible it has a chance maybe in the
back half of things to win the entire
event and there's something I want to
say Danny and I've been thinking about
this quite a bit yeah yeah of course the
underlying story of the entire world you
can't ignore it is Cova 19 and it's very
scary and everybody I should continue
practicing safety measures social
distancing sanitizing washing your hands
frequently
coughing it's your elbow please follow
the scientific advice but the reason why
I bring this up is we know that Roger
Bobb withdrew and we know the players
are playing under very difficult
conditions but and this is a big button
I feel for all the players and
specifically in before this round for
Yann the palm tree and if Maxime wins
this game for Maxime as well because if
Fabio no Caruana or Dingley rent we're
leading this event people like okay
there was a crazy circumstance around
the world very sad circumstances but you
know they overcame adversity but if
Yan or MDL or somebody else were to win
people might be like well the adversity
other player is like Fabiano calls
Fabiano not to win the event and I feel
like that is unfair to what Yan and
Maxie are showing in this event though I
think that this event should be taking
place no absolutely not
I'm happy to commentate on it now that
you know we are here but I do think the
players in this vid deserve the utmost
credit and respect and I think that in
some channels they're being disrespected
as what is you know Dingley right is
having a bad event but everyone is going
through similar ordeal it's a tough
situation I don't have any answers
unfortunately but I just wanted to say
that I think that it is unfair and so
many regards to everybody but in this
specific case - Maxime - Yan and for
players who you might expect to
potentially win the candidates - those
seven players agreed wholeheartedly I
think I think the chat does - and I
think I think nobody might my view is
nobody would neither judge if the event
didn't happen or would be canceled if
something happens there and continues to
worse in the health situation but also
as long as it's going on it's the chest
world's job to cover it and hopefully
it's a enjoyable experience for fans I
mean the truth is every everybody in the
chest world has their attention here and
and all all chess websites are doing a
great job I mean she chose 24 has had
fantastic coverage Magnus Carlsen I mean
you really can't say anything but good
things about chess 24 is work we know
that we're doing the best we can hear
people talk about the official feed a
broadcast I feel like everyone's doing
what they can to provide a great
experience but if the chest show ended
you know we would we would totally
understand and not hold it against it
you know a postponement even if it means
that MBL you know doesn't get his chance
to complete the termer the question is
whether he would get a second chance to
play Robert and whether her job would
come back anyway sorry that's a whole
other discussion I mean it's an
important discussion and one that has to
be had but I feel very strongly about
this and it's not any website in
particular any person particular but it
does seem that there's this kind of you
know thought process that if one of
these other players not named Caruana or
ding their own wins it's undeserved and
that is been working me so I just wanted
to address it and say that but I have
tremendous
spec for every player in this field they
are doing their best under unforeseen
circumstances and there has been some
excellent chess to this point including
is very game we have here so I'm going
to go back to the chest because King EE
was probably gonna say it's time to go
back to the chest tube because we're
looking at that seems advantage get
greater here King e8 it just feels you
know so and again we foreshadowed it to
back up in the analysis and it's it's
not in any way to just say that Rob and
I are right ever right we had Vishy
Anand and and fitted with us and but at
the time we were commentating on the
fact that neppo doesn't take time when
when he feels good I mean that's a weird
thing to say but it's just the truth
like nepeta plays fast he plays
confident part of the reason he's able
to do that everybody because he works
very hard at the board he's constantly
calculating even his opponents clocks so
his his opponents time so he can use the
clock as a weapon so when he started
slowing down here and then he took more
than 25 minutes on this move Robert and
then played c4 which was not a good move
I don't think in terms of the approach
in the position and it sort of was
already setting the tone that it feels
like this is gonna be Maxim's game to
win now whether he does so or not and
the reigns to be seen but yan has kind
of lost the threat a little bit on this
position and the move King e8 walking
your King back into the center when only
white can be in control of the open file
that's about to happen here this rook is
never gonna play again
spectators walking by right now are
probably thinking oh yelling can castle
on the next move Robert the king and
rook are back on their original squares
so why can't neppo just castle and
castling would have problems in of
itself but actually that is the
essential issue black is friend like
King d8 King c7 but even once you get
your king to c7 playing rook H to b8 is
hard because of Queen h7 so the threat
of Queen h7 is really strong and white
in the meantime it wants to figure out
the exact precise way to deliver a blow
to blacks position because can da King
c7 ideas like that are seeming the
obvious but Y can still expand g4 f 4
you can go look takes b6 and rook to be
won if you feel like trying to play on
the Queen side as well so the other
funny idea here Robert and this is kind
of a French ish idea my throat
whether it's concretely the best appear
or not is the it's an idea Brooke b5 in
some positions one of the points is that
you you actually kind of force the issue
for black if black doesn't want to take
in open lines then you're instantly
doubling and remaining in total control
over this side of the board but if they
do take it yes it's a pawn sacrifice but
it opens up files while blacks pieces
are still disconnected and you combine
that with threats of like rook b1 the
bishop relocating itself around and this
King in the center right from a
practical point of view this is a very
difficult position for black to play so
I'm constantly keeping my in fact he
plays rook before not exactly the same
idea no need to sacrifice the pawn but I
do I do like this approach of get
aggressive on the Queen side while
blacks dysfunction is at its high point
here let me ask you something
we saw kirill elect san'ko's sacrifice
in exchange against yun upon mushy if
knight c6 is nvl going to play rook f1
to be won and say rooks are not valuable
in a position without open files and
after Knight takes b4 C takes before
look at my pawns I'm starting to advance
over there on the Queen side not
creating havoc just yet but f4 f5 is
easier to punch through now that you
don't have an eye on e7 stopping it so
white can play flexibly on both sides of
the board here and it's very fascinating
success I mean you can go for this and
even like Bishop a5 if you want to win
material back you could even play Bishop
before like you said and like hold the
light squares I mean sorry hold the hold
the whole thing down I mean takes can be
met by like a5 even maybe not but the
point is White's compensation is very
very strong in positions like this
you know I'm not funny the best move I
guess we should just take here and not
overthink it yeah you can take and ask
questions later you're gonna pull it
Danny Ranch quote but the point is yeah
you you you kind of made this idea
happen with the exchange Sakon which is
hardly an exchange sac in a position
where the rook is just not playing by
the way
I was very wise this what what a shake
of that would be if we end up in a
position here where Maxime is
I mean
dominating then that would be something
that probably everybody else in the
tournament appreciates but every time
you can slow down the leader you give
everybody else a chance again so all
right well this game will obviously have
us on the edge of our seats the biggest
game of the round for sure but there are
several others going on do you want to
check on let's go let's go back to
Dingley run out alex anko's game just
because it's probably moved the furthest
along from where we were okay I honestly
haven't even looked at this game since
we last tuned in so well digging the
rent is down on the clock wasn't he up
like 30 minutes when we first looked
yeah he
we he's he's getting back to his winning
routes he beat five in a car wanna when
he was down all the time in the world so
he needs to be have less time in the
clock in order to win so we talked about
this position when Vinit and Vichy were
still with us and this idea of looking
at excuse me a vulnerable night in a
vulnerable Poland no concrete way to
take advantage of it though when black
takes back with the night safeguards it
one of the reasons we were worried about
the Queen taking because of this kind of
double threat idea very tricky to see
but Robert spotted it and now Bishop age
three played followed by Queen a4
I don't know how to evaluate this
position it's very double-edged black
has the center and with these pieces
kind of gearing up for a 94 plan I feel
like the kingside pressure could be very
real
if the bishop gets involved too but if I
can take a pawn if you want it yeah this
reminds me of you know kind of
bloomenfeld gambit type of structure
right because in that opening Waipa is d
take c6 and black plus F takes c6
and ends up giving up some Queen side
pawn for the play and Queen takes a 7 I
think would be met by Queen c7 which
threatens that trap the Queen with rook
8 so it forces white back with a move
like Queen to a4 and then you have the
exact ideas you were talking about Jenny
with either d4 and then e v e4 or 94
things of that nature so look at ding
there and go he says I'm gonna play b4
which tries to break open the Queen side
give him play it on that side of the
board but it feels like wife's position
just has to be not great here because
black has the semi open F file and
that's the better semi open file in this
position there's a little yeah it feels
a little desperate I would say
the kind of like it though and yeah I I
hate whites position but I like before
of all the moves that I don't feel like
the idea you highlighted of d4 is just
gonna be coming here at some point and
if the position closes in this way it
works as long as you can get a 5 and E
for to follow it up like you said I mean
you've got so many pieces ready here
that's why he played he played beat
fours then I can take on a seven so if
you a d4 whole I take it okay I see and
B seems very difficult to defend because
Queen c7 just take on c5 uh-huh and it
takes rook b1 and I don't even have to
worry about my queen being trapped and
instead I turn her and do an aggressor
here I love it
okay so be for a an aggressive try if
you really like it move yeah okay I'm
feeling yeah if d4 can't happen which is
kind of what black would want here
whatever you've coordinated all your
pieces you're trying to do something
with them on one side of the board you
hate it you hate the distraction but
maybe maybe black calls the bluff and
says well a pollen to pollen Thank You
uncle yeah sir and then here come and
happy belated birthday to Yasser cerimon
is his birthday yes yes a today that's
right i seven email you know happy
birthday yes 1960 by the way yep
pigma told me i told me doesn't look a
day over fifty nine I was thinking that
after taking on before and going full
Yeahs is 94 he's also going full yes
because he loves taking advantage of
squares so that d4 score is great for
the night it hits East six now the a7
pawn has to be watched out for it's
really becoming a bit of a mess and now
that I'm looking at it so I think maybe
looks are a bit deceiving it seemed like
black just had this overwhelming
initiative happening on the kingside in
the center but daily run very wisely
strikes back and it's not so easy to
protect his delicate pawn structure
yeah I mean it's I I keep thinking there
should be something very concrete here
and I'm looking at the kingside I kind
of want to start going for things like
this and just like for you know damn the
torpedoes so to speak you know an e6
pawn hanging f2 is hanging in this
position like this what yeah super
double edge because Bishop takes East
six check you go King h8 and our C takes
d5 I know my have two pawns hanging but
now at least I have this nice looking
pawn on d5 cementing official on e6 but
the king is super vulnerable no that's
uh I think and there's nice e3 ideas
there takes up to I mean I think that it
would take a while for both a computer
to arrive at a at a solid evaluation of
how unclear this could be and as well as
these players but I've come around to
hearing your point on b4 right if you're
in a position where your opponent's
pieces are primed right getting ready to
strike and all their coordination is
focused on one area of the board very
often that you should play a move like
b4 and as I as I like to say sometimes
ask questions later play it and then ask
questions later
I'm usually losing games a few moves
later after that but you know it's uh
but it's the right approach right from a
practical point of view you have to
create some sort of some sort of counter
play before your opponent just takes
over one area of the board by the way
because sorry you called the exchange
second yeah we got to go back to that
game because it's amazing right it's the
key game did we do it yep let's do it
and I mean honestly there wasn't too
much for me to call because rook before
was kind of a weird Square inviting 96
with the template but now it all makes
sense and you put f4 which is better
than my rook to be one suggestion and
the reason why is the pawn is it's
poison on b4 so if their Knight takes
before C takes before if you think rook
takes before will result in some trades
you would do it but white isn't going to
take that room you'll play Queen c3
adding another attacker on that pinned
rook and white will end up up a piece so
black has no bailout option in that
situation f4 f5 comes through very
quickly and maybe this is a very
important lesson
don't play the French defense against
the Frenchman with three names but also
a good robot
if any was just tuning in you're like
but camp like just castle and a lot of
these ditions know the king and rook
have already moved and that's not not
going back to it just as a joke it's
super critical right because it's the
reason why this attack is so dangerous
this is not not easy to deal with the
rook can't get in the game without
without the King coming further into the
fray and we already looked at some
critical lines I I found a way to show a
lot of losing moves but truthfully the
idea is it's very very straightforward
in positions like this white is just
crushing through just to show some fun
fun stuff if you went for lines like
this I mean just I just
yeah the Italian of roles itself that's
every Frenchman dream not every French
players dream well you used the word
Frey and if this were the fray there
would know how to save the life and a
driver did netbook wrong and what we
know we're young went wrong c4
feels like the culprit and I think it
just stresses he wasn't so familiar with
the position yep there were you know it
was a novel position but also there's so
many factors that are make blacks life
difficult that rook on G being the
critical and I think I said that from
the very beginning what he but as soon
as we saw the opening phase play out I
was like how was that rook on g8 gonna
come into the game and well the answer
it it might never black might resign
before that rook comes back over into
the action so I'm loving the way MBL is
playing he is excited to be here Vichy
was the one who was talking about that
how just the pure excitement might be
enough to catapult him into a top
position in this event but he's gone for
the whole shebang if you're just tuning
in that this was a very hyped and and
previewed game we talked about a lot of
the the stats that Rob and I looked into
about these two guys ultimately I think
we were a little surprised by the choice
of the French even though Yann has
played it against MVL before but the
winner were especially the moment it
came on the board I was just outing that
you know this is this is as risky a line
you can play as black so you're you're
really on the one hand bringing fighting
spirit which is great as the tournament
leader you still have the guts to go
from one of the most double-edged
positions in chess on the other hand
maxime was ready for it and he goes into
the line repeats metallic senko did in a
previous game but now goes full full
throttle with h5 and this move rook b1
was very complemented by vidit the point
is you want to play these ideas of queen
g4 but you can't when there's tricks
here so giving you this quick recap
Maxime finds first the very nice move
order which would be one to avoid that
then the Queen comes out to force the
dysfunction the rook to g8 to guard the
pawn the king to f8 now because you
don't want to play Bishop d7 and back up
and you're strapped with this bad Bishop
so you play King f8 so that you can keep
this Bishop a6 option open but Maxime
blows open the position and then the
more this went on it felt like Queen d1
was also played very fast by Maxime so
he was still in prep but despite you on
finding the best move for a while
eventually he kind of suck them to not
being comfortable here and and plays
this move c4 which we felt really really
gives white that advantage back you can
see the engine agrees and it's kind of
been all and BL ever since we're
expecting this one to get to get real
spicy real fast I'm like I just I just
got a sneak preview to your game of the
day video lol yeah I felt like I was a
student because I was watching you and
you were going through the motions you
mention how I'm did it nobody nobody
watches those things anyway I think
you're the guy refreshing 17,000 times
so I do appreciate that
see you say I don't support you people
think that I'm not here that takes
commitment to keep my self esteem up you
guys any idea how hard Robert has to
work to do that to keep this guy off the
ledge well I mean we did just reference
the fray so I guess it's only that well
continue don't raise your voice
present me one last choice my only
choice is to head back over to the
Caruana game with wang hao because i was
i was told by someone in chat shame on
me for listening to that that maybe Wang
Hale blundered I'm gonna get blacks okay
here I'm looking at that f3 pawn Vishy
Anand who by the way commented when he
was here about the English attacking bad
structure with this with this pawn on g5
was really in sight by the way he's one
of the world's leading experts I know
because I'm he's
fan hashtag guilty and also because my
repertoire is you know Robert is
basically built on an ons repertoire
right I play the same types of
approaches against opens against the
Sicilians he's played a lot of these
English attacks of his games or model
game model games and when he called for
this idea that oops
um did he call for that to the my scream
went
my name is hilarious clippable moment
the screen just went nuts guys but hey
we're back you see how quickly I can
diagnose tech issues these days I have
learned I have grown up so fast so I
think we should meet you change your
title from im2 IT Danny wrench but I was
trying to highlight here when that went
crazy is that the pollens being broken
is something have to worry about on the
white side of Sicilians and Vichy called
for f5 and I really liked that idea
because it's pointing out that if this
if this pawn storm if you will if the
storm stops then the pollens are weak
and extended and separated and so f5 was
a great move to change the structure and
go for that and anyway so I look at the
position and still think that wang hao
is doing just fine with the f3 pawn
that's all i wanted to say my god i need
some more coffee here we've got a lot of
people with us who knows why thanks for
being here
tuning in to chess columns coverage
Robert take the wheel look as I was
suggesting earlier I like long house
chances I'm not saying he's better I
think objectively the positions level
but there are these imbalances in the
position note the pawns in f3 and h2
weaker than their counterparts on g7 and
h7 but also note that night on g3 is
stronger than the knight f6 then I have
6 is sort of keeping blacks position
together the 19 g3 is looking to hop
right into the f5 square posing some
very legitimate challenges to blacks
entire set up so when I'm looking at
setting it's very imbalanced despite the
material being the same people it was
just equal material no look at the
dynamics here the Queen side we keeps
off with a light square as on that side
of the board I'm still concerned about
that in the long run if white is able to
go King to c3 at some moment and then
potentially work their way up the board
that will be a legitimate issue for
black as well and they have three pawn
the h2 point I mentioned at the
beginning will come right back to it
because now that you'll figure out what
white wants in the long run hey what
does black one like lots to pile up some
pressure on those squares Bishop takes
f3 in the immediate position would not
be a good move I don't think because
Knight a5 low I got misty for but not if
I was even stronger I'll give you my
exchange take on d1 an overtake c7 check
and your King is
that's a B in all sorts of trouble just
be gentle please yeah this is gonna be
bad
okay so that's not going to happen
which is why Fabi gets away with 93 but
let's say one cow plays the move that
you were calling for earlier for
different reasons but if I just then I
know I always get a little scared when
there's something on e 7 and maybe I
should be apparently but I kind of want
to just stop White's plan here's what I
want to do philosophically if the
tactics work out if I can just stop the
counter play positionally Black has the
edge with these pawns under fire
so how do we stop how do we stop the
counterplay what's the best move here
for black I'm wondering when or if we
should throwing him like c4 and the
reason I'm playing c4 is not just
because they taxed a bishop in one turn
but it gives my dish one eise Evan more
room to work with right the whole point
of nine-to-five is of course to attack
the 27 but the bishop has no safe
squares so by playing c4 you have a
bishop we just get out the way move
bishop
get out the way get out the way bishop
well done
get out of the way by the way c-4 played
what c4 played here but look what Yann
just did a very big committal decision
by jana palma she that's risky chess but
i mean we've already we've already been
critical of the position and black has
been in trouble i if she'd like that
move them i feel like that's a that's
almost they must find you either can
survive the position now or not because
if Maxime isn't ready to take and keep
it open you will get room now finally
for your king you'll finally be able to
complete that development so it's it's
time to fight a concrete line if you're
a VL you're definitely thinking about
taking on f6 humph asan gotta be right
because if the position closes up how is
white going to win the game you can play
Bishop c1 Bishop e3 so let's keep these
two different ideas in hand right one
idea is to take on open up the center
and the King side the other is to keep
that side the board closed like Bishop
c1 make three and figure out what
to do after that
maybe I Brooke b5 continue pressing but
if you take on passant the clear
downside is that black gains new
activity that he didn't previously have
you can take with a knight on f6 which
puts pressure on the h5 pawn maybe then
I will hop into e4 and you're going to
take with the pawn on f6 which can give
you some rook g8 night at five not just
an attacking chance but sort of a bind
in the position and blackening mister
playing f6 to f5 Knight f6 94 these kind
of ideas of course what will make moves
not allow all this to happen but it's a
critical moment because the entire
nature of the game is about to change to
take shape for the future here let's
look a little bit the slow idea because
rook b5 to me right away
was also a candidate move now the
problem everybody is there's no there's
no Bishop c1 or rook b5 and then taking
up a son later right you either you can
do it now or it goes away
so let's look at something like this I
guess the Queen moves I I think we both
agree this is probably not as good as
taking an opening but if you look at the
position is there some way that white
keeps an edge and this kind of stuff one
idea
Robert long-term of this is if the
bishop is putting pressure on the night
and that night is such a key defender
for f5 you know where I'm going you can
see plain I'm gonna punch this through
yeah and if g4 comes in and we can
undermine this key protector the king is
not totally out of Dodge yet so I I was
thinking about that idea while you were
analyzing he takes f6 and I I guess I
would still expect this but I wouldn't
be surprised if he says you know what I
think the position is so bad for black
yes you're helping something but it
still takes just enough moves that I'm
gonna launch this new plan where g4 is
on the agenda I don't know why me why
doesn't edge here - I'm gonna pull a
video and go full nuance on you I think
throwing in rupee five is actually an
accurate and the reason why guys because
when black eventually plays rook h2 b8
and tries to take on the B file yes like
over B and that's like a G for the move
that you want to play the point it's
gonna spin that's where you're going yep
exactly
rook takes b5 happens and if we go for
this exact same line but instead of
playing Brooke b5 leave the Queen on a
5d so just like go yeah yeah I was
showing the end of the line there is
that the pawn is pinned everybody and so
you can't take here although Bishop
takes you seven is so crazy but okay yes
yeah so that's the idea you want to
avoid you keep the rook on before and do
the same plan that Robert wants bring
the bishop here rook over and now you
can play g4 and actually this looks
fantastic for white because when you
take on before I can take even with the
pawn honestly but taking the bishop and
I'm attacking your queen so I gain a
tempo compared to the other line and I
don't have to worry about my Bishop on
a3 being under attack so it's a pretty
interesting little game of cat-and-mouse
there and one that white should be happy
to leave the rook on before for
I mean as much as the instinct is still
taunt for son not just cuz I don't get
to do it very often and I don't speak
French so it's one of the few things I
get to say in French on Poisson but with
that with that said I mean it looks like
White's best chances might actually be
to go back to the idea we've been
calling for for a long time
the the slow-jam idea that is common in
these winter Wars not as fun as the
crazy poisoned pawn lines you get when
White's taking g7 but these ideas okay
well he plays what b5 which is the same
okay so he's officially answering our
question he agrees that this plan of
taking is not as good as this idea this
is what we're gonna see but he's played
rugby 5 first hi Ted you convinced me in
the end it was not as accurate to play
rugby 5 so maybe this is a mistake by
Maxime or maybe it's just a good move in
or maybe it's the same maybe I'll take
on B 6 some moment I'm not entirely sure
but he throws in before I'm just trying
to understand the benefit of the move
yes attacks the Queen on this turn but
once Queen a6 happens you have to having
gained a tempo you know what you can do
is maybe you can just take a play chief
or it's just straight forward you're
just gonna go full-on just all in baby
that looks pretty good don't think I
mean I think you made a great point
about maybe there's no need for the
tempo but if he feels like this line is
forced then and he doesn't like how
black deals with this so what about like
rook takes b5 here so I know we're
giving up the Queen side pawn to get the
f5 pawn take the pawn ok
oh you take on that fight first don't
you yeah that was what I thought that's
really smart because what I was trying
to accomplish was if you took me on b5
instead trying to get my Queenie deeply
and we had right
but even though you've f6 check probably
so it's okay complicated still but I
agree I wanted to avoid that Queen trade
and I think this is okay I still think
you're right I mean like okay pieces
have come off maybe black has better
chance of surviving here but white is
white is definitely in control very
dangerous
two sides of the board as a means of
entry and
[Music]
this is scary by the way Queen age six
already met by Bishop to see one so
these variations we're looking at will
probably not be in vain maybe not
exactly but yeah things are heating up
here and Maxime is uh is bringing the
pressure Wow well neppo and has played
the best chess overall for sure of
anybody so far that's why he's a full
point ahead of the field at going into
this round but this would be one of
those games that would really come back
to haunt you maybe in terms of not just
losing your lead but you know I wonder
if the decision again to play the French
versus some of their success he's had
but okay again it's right now I think
it's all just speculation so I just I
just won't speculate but anyway my brain
is going to I feel like we've spent too
much time prepping I'm thinking about
what the other options were that he
didn't go for and okay we'll see where
it goes I just mean it just feels
throughout this entire game has been so
easy for max man to play and this time
is beating on the French right we're not
beating up I'm just say but it is it is
a choice that like you said it's been
easy for max seems so far sorry good no
the time is about level so that's sounds
in theory oh well isn't black keeping
pace but Yann is such a quick player but
to his credit so is Maxime so we have
two of the quicker players well-prepared
players who move at lightning speeds but
the resulting position here is just
clearly easier to play for white because
blacks position is on the verge of
collapsing all of the time and from
Maxime point of view he will sacrifice
upon the Queen side if you can get that
attack going on the Kings side and you
know for it Yann it's it's just the
potential of losing on the spot and for
Maxime it's like whether I'm going to
win or a black has just enough to
survive a position like this a black is
clearer than one on the back foot
shout-out to a Shane Matthews they're
from Facebook watching us from Jamaica
I like Jamaica
couple times I like it
and you know if there was a concrete
following has it at all 400 viewers of
on Facebook we we see you guys on every
platform we appreciate the positivity
and and all the all the things you guys
have brought here today
great great heaven whatever we got here
about 12,000 of you with us in English
you speak other languages remember we
are live in many different many
different non-english languages Vichy
and non regularly joining the Spanish
coverage as well and alright Bishop III
played this is this is getting real
tough for yon I think the lines we've
been looking at Robert I don't see any
any way out there is no there is no
other move to avoid the fact that white
is in control when white wants chief for
white we'll get you for the night could
come to g3 if it wanted to back it up
and this night will be removed when
Maxime says so so he's gone Chuck Norris
Maxime giveth and taketh away
well the only possible idea I can come
up with for black has some kind of rough
g8 g6 and hope that that works but I
still don't think it does it just it's
too slow you're not actually stopping
white from any of his plans and another
idea that Y can even try to make happen
to some moment is as a rich e8 you can
play Bishop c5 force the can file can I
just crush you down I love this okay I
just want a higher the positional point
because you know I love pawn structures
if you open up the d4 square for the
knight I just might I might fall out of
my chair I'm gonna make me so happy to
play white shout-out to Steph who's
watching the chest show with her
boyfriend even though it's against your
will
we appreciate you supporting a nasty
habit thanks for tuning in all right
what do you think
I think this position looks terrible for
black and yeah he has to go rook H to be
a that's my taking is to hope that
despite the ugly looking position with
the liquidation comes superior drawing
chances than he has now but I think that
Maxime is just gonna continue pressing
for it as he should
he's there's no risk in White's position
let's let's try to do a the thing we do
will be predict a really deep line Zhu
Li do the thing Robert do the thing you
get that records
no I didn't Robert do the thing let's do
that thing what we predict really deep
line sorry that's a reference for those
who get it alright
rook b8 we're gonna go Bishop take c7
King takes and are we playing g4 first
and go for the line you like or we
wanted to we're particularly g4 I like
g4 okay
[Music]
what now
I was hoping you'd tell me cuz it looks
just not fun for black you I was taking
on b5 don't look fun so and go with that
um what other movers even coming to mind
you taking on g4 looks not promising
I'm sorry instead of taking mp5 but yeah
what what is the follow-up there is that
just queen g6 or is there a fiver
I think queen g6 looks pretty
straightforward right yeah I mean f5
also looks very strong maybe even take
on b6 and then just yeah you have to
take on b6 first because that way you
don't give up any Queen side material
and just play rock f1 f v g6 all this
stuff and just cope me but you like but
where do we do that
everyone takes b6 now but then the rooks
gonna take and then forget for one
wow you're running away from the Queen
side okay interesting I mean I'm just
not giving you any Queens I counter
chloride there and it honestly it's a
great line but you because it really
just highlights how tough this position
is for black right I mean the king is
going nowhere I gave you g4 and the B
file and you still are in huge trouble
here with Queen g6 + f5 coming yep
this is a sad position so I just don't
see a way to fend off White's obvious
plan
can you be can you think of anything
that stops this I really can no we're
taking you seven we're playing g4 and
then then the nice thing about being in
an advantage like that is White Robert
you get to react right so it's kind of
like you get to say Bishop takes these
seven g-force coming and then what does
black come up with do they take do they
do something crazy because when they
start feeling that kind of pressure you
know now it's easy to just react to
whatever bad plan they choose right
there picking poisons
this is this is not good because Bishop
c5 is a pretty devastating threat to not
just Bishop e7 and g4 so again why that
is so let's say you play I don't know
even like a look at any anything to try
to safeguard the King and when this move
comes in I freaked out about the idea of
getting the d4 square for a good reason
this would be omg's or snaps in fact if
you take I take here I mean if you move
the rook on the B file you lose the rook
on the B file this Knight d4 I mean this
this kind of position is just falling
apart so we've already predicted I think
rightfully so rook b8 is pretty much the
only move here for yan because at least
then you can meet Bishop c5 but taking
that would be bad but then we're gonna
see we think Bishop takes e7 and g4 or
yeah
bill bill
so now it's just a matter of time when
it's actually played because we've been
calling for this for a while and Maxine
just has to respond he said I think you
put it well you just need to react
yeah whatever Yan does and Yan is trying
so hard digging deep to find a way to
survive because if Yan is able to
survive this he goes into the second
half of the tournament with a full point
lead for sure but if you lose this game
now Alves and he's tied from first with
maxium I'm feeling unhappy because the
standings remind everybody we do have
more than almost 14,000 of you again
with us and some of you may be rolling
out of bed on the west coast it's not
quite 7 a.m. others of you just need a
refresher to see that beautiful man with
the man bun sitting atop the standings
but as Robert said he may not be there
for very long MBL wins this game he will
be tied there and probably in first in
terms of tie breaks and and yeah let's
head back to our bird's-eye view since
we're taking a reset here and let you
let you get a high-level peek at what's
going on on every board the one the one
that is having a little bit more people
actually Wow the Dingley Ren game is
getting crazy
because he did indeed go for both a 7
and B 6 the Fabiano game Robert a 4
right the American strikes back to try
to undermine this last move see 4 we got
a whole lot to talk about we're gonna
take a very very quick break when we
return more of Round seven here chest
coms coverage of the 2020 feat a
candidates continues
[Music]
you
and these games are heating up we have
fire onboard thank you Alexei shear off
what a great title for a book anyway
we're looking at all four games here
from the bird's-eye view because I gotta
let my partner take the wheel I mean the
big board has the car wanna game I'm
worried you're worried about fabi's
position there Vashti the growth has
gone for the line we predicted that
might be crazy
Bingley Ren went pawn grabbing and may
regret it Robert take the wheel
I don't we start with this game that you
have on screen here between ding li Ren
and Carillo at senko and alexei go of
course had the heartbreak in round six
against in each theory he blundered at
the end of a tough defense against a
nice giri he'd lost that game you really
didn't feel like he deserved to lose it
but right now with a black piece again
seeing the red his position looks like
it's very good for black but there are
some practical difficulties here if some
trades were to happen the pawn on e6 is
a target white has these pawn island the
chain e to the H file and that is nice
and safe here so I think the critical
decision that elects anko is thinking
about because he can't capture the pawn
a3 was nice e3 hanging his knight takes
me to check or Knight to d5 he has both
of these as options Knight takes a 2 is
a little bit more forcing you sacrificed
your knight to win the knight on f3 but
then you lose the pawn on e6 and that
feels dangerous so you know it's the
beat for pawn the end of it is also
hanging and you will be down the pawn at
least that's how you envision the
position and you like do I have
sufficient compensation because it's a
bit unclear you have that great Bishop
on have 3 in that variation but whether
or not that is sufficient for full
compensation is another story and
besides Knight takes 295 is also
possibility we're treating move
attacking the Queen and then giving
blacks the opportunity to go take that
pawn a3 next I really like that that was
my first instinct when we spied the
position during our break there was to
was to save the night so you could take
a three cuz worst case scenario even if
it's traded for c4 straight up a 3-cell
but you make a good point that maybe
that's actually the wrong way to think
about it because that's kind of the warm
and cozy move right I'm
feeling uncomfortable let me come back
defend my pieces but sometimes that can
backfire if the positions already on
full tilt maybe you got to go all-in
right because just looking at it if
white goes to almost any square and we
do trade east six is gonna be a problem
and I'm losing all my chances with my
knight on d5 losing my craziness also it
manages a tactic that I didn't see it
for his Bishop takes East six check
instead of moving the Queen okay I just
I just went Queen d4 instead of quitting
five which i think was better but this
is also there's also spicy the worry of
this line is you may see b3 at the end I
don't know I thought maybe we could keep
passed pawns going but perhaps not
perhaps just c4 is a problem so
oh that's very tactical sharp position
and both players have to be on hot high
alert
but also I want to note Danny that
Dingley Ren he was up 30 minutes then
down like five minutes and now he's up
almost thirty minutes again this has
been a volatile game on the clock if we
had the whole timestamps it would it
would look like this but you already
said I mean the man from China needed to
find himself I kind of foreshadow that
if he has any chances to win this event
in the back half of things it may need
to get made mean of victory is required
here as white against the lowest rated
player in the field but in real Alex
Enco is uh he's not really any worse in
the position right now and so as we know
he's the youngest player in the
tournament he used the wild card given
the spot by the organizers there
and we'll see what you can do here he's
obviously on the clock only 14 minutes
13 now to make 14 moves if you're
looking for the experience of following
the games yourself and choosing your
invention remember you can go to chess
columns live server or trust calm slash
events and pick any game you want but 14
moves have to be played here by black
with only 13 minutes left
I think the position once he finds a
move here he makes that determination
the resulting position will not be that
difficult to find moves in so he's just
choosing this critical moment do I play
Knight AC to check and liquidate
simplify the position or do I play
Knight d5 and then go B takes a three I
give up my seat pawn but I saw the
strong bishop on b7 it's not like
White's King is the safest where it is
with that Bishop on that long diagonal
so I think it's really all about this
decision and Alex anko is wise to be
spending his time right here
early this whole line with rook takes
wouldn't be good in the end of black can
play e5 and then II for but this
position is so is so wild and crazy'
move is a move where you're giving up
everything to just hold on to the
squares and keep the bishop bet I have
no idea I know that Alex Enco is
probably gonna play a better move than I
would I do know that I definitely have
confidence at him to do that don't don't
tell me how you really feel the okay you
you were saying at the break that the
game that to you is getting a little
more clear as far as who's at least
playing for a win whether it becomes a
win is the one between Fabiano car one
and one Hal because with Fabi playing
this this a4 idea it's a little more
desperate to try to simplify the
queenside that he played a few moves ago
we'll back up and show it after b5
rather than the ideas that we've seen
for a long time at least Robert has been
touting for awhile the long-term chances
white has those are totally gone because
black has gotten this great Queen side
expansion the pieces are active if I'll
be trying to simplify this pressure and
maybe hope to hold on but your thoughts
on where this is going
it's not going in the direction that
Bobby would like it to go that's for
sure because when you see a position
like this it's still all about those
kings eyed pawns and f3 is weak h2 is
not that much better then night on f5
bish one g5 configuration it looks
menacing
but it's not amounting to much of
anything f6 is protected you can always
just defuse the situation as is needed
to f3 point can be captured because the
fisherman f1 is hanging with check and
so many variations so it's really rookie
5 for instance then I say I'll go ahead
and take on f3 and as we trade pieces
there's rip d1 check at the end they're
scooping up that Bishop and only black
can be better in end games like this oh
I like longhouse position I think he's
going to try to press this one and
considering fabi's down a little bit in
the clock and the next bunch of moves
are not that easy to play I think that
one how you know he should be copying in
this position well I mean the question
really I guess in hindsight well Bobby
may be fighting for a draw now was was
it was it as early as moved 16 g4 which
you really didn't like and maybe not
even as much for the concrete evaluation
but just from the practical fact you
felt like White was you know creating
some potential problems for him for
himself and ultimately that would get
black winning chances but maybe white
was okay even with this kind of shot of
f5 that vichy and not found if he had
played a little bit differently here
when we had talked about 90 g5 being a
move because of this c4 idea and opening
the light squares and Bobby didn't go
for that I actually think that this this
idea especially with this c4 move might
have been actually key for white in
hindsight to maintain the balance and
perhaps perhaps he just wasn't ready for
the for the friskiness that that is and
ever since Bishop c5 black is if black
has been bringing pieces out and pushing
the Lions back and and now the English
attack weakness gone wild I know I know
something about those those of those
situations x-rated edition I've lose a
lot of games his white with these kind
of positions I mean jokes aside you push
for an attack and then the Queen's come
off the board and all those pawns you
pushed we got here in a different way it
was a Petra off the Queen's works
don't move 14 but black is holding all
the cards here yeah and you mentioned
the English attack that's what they say
about the Sicilian the longer the game
goes the better blacks chances are
oftentimes Sicilian black gets just
totally rolled over and crushed because
of a swift mating attack but the
structure is so nice for black and in
this end game it's so clear the split
King side pawns are worse then the
connect the King side pawns blacks
bishops on c5 and d5 could you ask for
better pieces not really and the king
the black king is a bit more active the
white king is for now stuck on the first
rank I've liked everything about blacks
position here agreed even though the you
know the balance is seeming to be there
right now with the activity from white
all the long-term features favor black
to be the one grinding this one away
let's back up and go back to the game of
the round if you will MVL versus net but
we got a question from chess TV chat
waste time 2007 wants to know as we
bring up that board
if neppo can play g6 and rook c8 at some
point I I don't I don't think so I mean
so it's white to play here
there's probably earlier position maybe
earlier okay maybe here instead okay of
uh of this whole trade there was g6 and
rook g8 interesting but before this even
before and before you go Breger of being
here
I guess it's still just super I mean I
don't think so and all these lines you
know you're taking and taking here I
don't know there was ever a chance and
he only just asked the question so I
don't know if he was asking about
earlier positions I mean the point is
the idea is interesting you want to try
to defend but I just don't think there's
enough
and this is the line robber and I looked
at earlier where you take a five rather
than trading and bring the Queen to b3
so maxime kind of maintains control over
where the board's gonna open up if you
take here you take back and you've
opened up both ideas of entering this
way as well as kept it an idea about
five if tags you might even play Knight
g3 instead of taking with the Queen
right away it's possible to take here
and then the Queen and Knight are
getting dirty over here on these these
squares with the king so this is just
getting so scary for Maxine you wonder
if Nippo has calculated some resource
Robert we know that how he defends
sometimes it's kind of out we see like a
car like a more defend right calculating
and there's some sort of small
resourceful trick or nuance in one of
these forcing lines but I just don't see
that right now I don't see how he how he
saves the day here well that night g3
move you point out is extremely
important because after each takes f5 in
the Y position if you plate Queen takes
f5 black plays Queen e6 and the offering
the Queen trade in fact what it looks
forced to trade Queens otherwise that
black Queen goes into g4 and wreaks
havoc on that so the board Queen trades
are not good for white when there's an
outside passed pawn in that a 7-point
and they're already liquidating there
aren't that many pieces remaining but
you're giving black and outside pastor
that his Knights are very bad at
corralling pawns on the other side of
the board so I would not play Queen
takes a5 you wait and play Knight g3
that way you can just sign exactly how
you will take on a5 and as the pause
like going anywhere
yep you can take that v with check or or
enter in with the Queen first depending
but something like Queen b6 might be
possible but now maybe you take with
check and again this is just you're
hoping for some sort of way to defend
your King and get the Queen's off the
board to use the idea of Robert has
talked about already which of course is
the past a pawn but other short of a
blunder by maxime it's very clear who's
in control we expect to see the move
Knight to g3 here and neppo is it's
fighting may be groveling for a draw
already as early as move 30
oh yeah he's going to have to grovel and
he I think you also raised a good
analogy in a way to him camara him say
Hikaru in the way that they defend
because some people are happy
Corie akan is the greatest example this
getting a worse position being very
passive and shuffling pieces around
saying hey you can't beat me I'm solvent
enough other players look for aggressive
defense and that sounds really isn't
that kind of the best defense is a good
offense you know who loves defense daryl
morey shout out to Darrel love you buddy
his Darrell in the chat I was even
looking at her earlier got it
well what I was gonna say was just that
you create problems for your opponent
prey tactics that they have to be on
alert for and when they feel tied down
in the position they don't bend stop
being aggressive themselves so Yan an
e-card with excellent in that regard but
in this position it just feels so much
easier to play for white because where
is blacks um counter-attack where's that
counter punch coming from I don't see
where so 93 feels like just the move
that Maxime needs a play and continue
pressing on well we've talked a lot
about these two guys let's remind
everybody we do have more than 14,000 of
you with us who these guys are
you haven't haven't been paying too much
attention Maxime vache the Grob number
one in France number one in your hearts
29 years of age and the last-minute
replacement here in the candidates may
be about to get a victory that ties him
atop the leaderboard against his
opponent yonder pom Nishi is
is also 29 years old number one in
Russia maybe now number two coming into
the tournament but he has been the star
of the show there in Russia and this
might be the first the first time he
slowed down at all if he ends up losing
this one is black there'll be a lot to
talk about of course if indeed that does
happen but I want to take a second to
step back and bring up our bird's-eye
view again because all of the games are
going fast right now and we're gonna do
our best as they near time control to
keep up with them but remind you again
we saw five moves now rattled off
quickly in that Caruana game a series of
force exchanges that you kind of
highlighted Robert actually happened on
the board but but no game has changed
more than the Geary grisha game
unfortunately it might just be headed
for peace well let's take a look at that
one we really haven't given them too
much love so let's dive into Geary and
grishnack and at least just show what
the forcing approach was that the
Dutchman took to it to rid himself of
his isolated pawn starting starting back
here he started advancing the D pawn and
maybe he already just had simplification
on the brain here he just wanted to get
everything traded off the board and he's
gonna be down a pawn but he's got the C
file his counter play and I'm uh he's
everything about Lincoln yeah these end
games are complicated and I always think
I've got a calm ski when I see positions
like this because Ghana was superb with
his technical play in end games I mean
just really phenomenal and you can think
of other players that are more well
known to the broader public like Karpov
and of course the world champions but
when I look at this position look at
rook c8 played saying go take a seven
I need play I don't want to make a move
like rook a passively defending a pawn
no I am going to defend my position by
getting aggressive rook c2 Bishop c5
going after the f2 pawn hey I have a
passed pawn you say isolated D pawn I
say passed D pawn I'm gonna start trying
to push that one through d4 d3 Brooks c2
Bishop c5 elroy strikes again all these
moves are a quite easy to spot for black
and then for what you're like wait
should I go pawn grabbing and take a
seven and play in this man
and I mean look at the white king the
black king is active the white king is
stuck at home with Bishop c5 coming
think about King f5 King g4 and I don't
want to short out it I don't want to you
know cuz turns out Darrell was right
again best defense is a good offense
right and it is an instructive point
though regardless this is something that
you know in a lot of people's games if
you're tuning in come on be honest with
yourself a lot of times the reaction is
to just defend the material right or
even you know try to move the pawn to
safety but here 100 percent the dimmer
wretzky active rook school of chess it's
almost always worth more than a pawn if
it's close to equality and here you see
that even the engines agree this is the
best idea if you give it up Black has a
couple options I mean you can go rook c2
right away with Bishop c5 I think that's
that's probably the best especially
because you also attack b2 but I like
what you said I mean the D pawn combined
with the pressure the black has these
pieces as far outweighing the threats of
these to pass was here they're just too
slow yeah it was interesting to me as
well because your initial reaction was
that this was liquidating and say like
an equal endgame and I just don't like
words like equal endgame because I'm
almost symmetrical and equal in size rod
which is which is what I meant right I
mean here certainly that's not the case
right and black is better and I think
that white will actually have a tough
task heaven and eesh
you go from trying to surprise your
problem with a novelty and move 10 to
getting this position this is not what
was on the drawing board and for gosh
oak who's had six draws to this point
you know that you have a draw in your
back pocket if you want it but keep on
pressing this is the type of endgame
that turns you in from a strong player
it's a potential Challenger for the
World Championship you need a win games
like this and of course that will take
some mistakes from a nice Giri
but Anisha is prone to making mistakes
just like every other player in the
world again if you're just joining us
the quick TLDR of this game as Robert
said was a novelty on move 10 from
Romany theory which was applauded
especially at first by viddy gujrati who
was with us it looked really interesting
as far as the tricks but Grichuk takes
the time and this time it was the right
thing to do he comes up
not only one aggressive move but then
after this move d4 he finds the
super-creative Queen d4 in Queen G for
that Vichy and on loved as well and the
point is that as the position was
simplified if people are wondering
Robert why did Gary go for this in game
where he gives up the d5 pawn well if he
if he doesn't play d5 here I mean maybe
he's worried that black is just gonna
put a piece on d5 and and start to just
slowly grind against the pawn
I mean hindsight being 20/20 if we look
at the board here on the analysis screen
and then the live position I think Gary
might be regretting this move d5 you
know and anything else that kind of sits
on the position probably maintains a
better balance for white so what was it
you think that he panicked about he took
a lot of time on this move by the way
more than 30 minutes before going for
this
I just from very early when I had a
Vichy and did it talking about this
position I said which side would you
rather play with and I think I was
pretty clear that I would rather play
from the black side in this position I
think that's what Andy was feeling and
what did it jokes about earlier with
that repetition when the Queen went in
g4 with Bishop a vision of G - honestly
Anisha is regretting not doing that
right now and determine like the
candidates there's so many you know
other elements besides your own game you
have to think about how does this look
and you're not just you know sitting
there playing a casual chess game online
there's a lot of stake and maybe in
retrospect it wasn't embed of him to
repeat because he wasn't comfortable
with the position the isolated pawn in
the endgame especially as you just point
out correctly when it's potentially
block hated it becomes really weak and
right with that I said a pawn white is
not very active black will just operate
around it and so he gets rid of it
perhaps not realizing to the full extent
that this position is quite tough for
white
well he does go for the simplification
what her fish' page three was an
interesting way to be down the pawn if
you had to choose in hindsight
again now that we're in the light
position it's easier to understand fully
that that this sacrifice of the
queenside pawns that certainly giri
anticipated when he went for this may be
regrettable right because now that we're
in the position with Grichuk having just
played Brooksie to the threat of Bishop
c5 the Russian is in control and
speaking of the Russian let's remind
everybody of griffix pedigree cuz it's
strong sasha is strong he's a multiple
time world blitz champion he's played in
two candidates more than a few times
four in total which is which is really
saying something and
and yeah I mean his experience finally
pay off for Sasha right if he won this
game he would be right there amongst
amongst the leaders especially if Maxime
helps him out and slows down his
countryman so maybe it's time for
Grichuk to strike a nice giri did win a
big game yesterday against alex anko but
right now he's he's gonna be on the
opposite side I think the second
youngest player in the event is is gonna
be on the worse side of things here for
the rest of the same game who are they
playing for they're playing for a chance
to challenge Magnus Carlsen for the
world title so I don't forget it that's
why we're here why this event is
happening that's why you should hit the
follow button and subscribe and don't go
anywhere else because our show is the
most fun right Robert if you say so
maybe nobody else has Robert Hess on
their show that is a fact it is just a
true statement can't argue with that
we'll play it sir there you go I know it
Robert hates it when he can't argue with
things I say so
Touche to me I don't know where else to
go
I wanna I keep wanting to go back to the
boss may the grove neppo game because
it's it's the one with probably the most
implications in terms of the standings
but maybe the car won and Wang Hao game
deserves our attention actually
especially because that force line that
you predicted is on is now on the board
so let's go there okay let's see you
so Brooke when you took the pawn to b5
even material right same material
opposite colored bishops both sides of a
knight both sides of rook and three
pawns but those pawns are in the
opposite sides of the board white has
the extra pawn on the Queen side where
his king is black has an extra pawn on
the Kings side where his king is but
just images excuse me interesting to
note that dynamic now in this position
my first gut instinct is play Brooke f2
and attack two pawns at the same time
and I imagine there must be something
wrong with it because otherwise one how
it played very quickly
there's always Knight d6 check winning
the c4 pawn that's a bit annoying huh
this is more challenging than I thought
I really black would just be better and
clearly so but it seems like white has
these resources very much keeping him
alive well it it does give credit to
Fabiano for being very accurate and in
this
willingness to go for this risky line
because we were looking this position
and felt like rookie five was was danger
Will Robinson right danger Fabiano it
was like you can't go for this Bishop a
3/4 line and lose f1 at the end and I
don't think you're wrong to say that it
seems like only black can be better but
now in hindsight looking at it and
you're voting for this which is you
trade it off your f3 pawn for the b5
pawn right you kind of if you look at it
from here you're like well clearly
that's that's not an equal trade right
white has gotten rid of the much weaker
pawn and I think we gotta give Bobby
some resourceful credit here right
because now this is at least gonna be a
race instead of a grind Robert where
Wang Hao is playing for two results you
highlighted it well we got two versus
one right two versus one it's a it's a
pure race here in terms of who's gonna
be faster and there are some theoretical
end games that deserve discussion just
briefly rook and Bishop versus a lone
Brook and both sides obviously having
their kings is a theoretical draw if the
pieces are starting in the center same
with rook and Knight versus rook rook
and Bishop is much harder for the
defensive side rook and Knight is much
easier for the defensive side in those
end games so you start thinking in that
manner this I do because when you think
about pawns racing down the board you
think maybe I'm you sacrifice a piece to
stop those pawns and both players for
sure are thinking about that as this
game continues but I do expect rook F to
block the try scooped up the H to pawn
white to try to go get the c-4 pawn and
then it's a it's a real pawn race here
shout-out to chess TV chat poison to vi
wants to know why not Bishop d5 we'll
look at it real quick cuz I don't think
it's good but mature by maybe just 93
actually pork
yeah we try to answer questions where
possible this looks good there is no
discovered check because we take your
checker and after after black moves you
either taking f6 first or your waiting
the bishop so Bishop d5 is probably not
a good move I think Roberts rook d5
makes sense
I think Knight d5 is interesting
bringing another piece into it because
we highlighted the Kings on opposite
sides of the board for the the race
factor robber but there's also a still a
little bit of a of a danger factor for
white here to me as I look at a move
like this and I get worried a little bit
about the King's safety
my I mean there might be 96 checks still
in these positions I thought I could go
here with a tempo and then maybe go back
for some c3 stuff I'm just here's what
I'm trying I'm trying to get the pawn to
c3 and if you don't take it now your
rook f2 is like super dangerous or even
a bishop before okay not right away but
I think that night oh wow c3 nice I like
that move anything that optimizes
winning chances okay so even if it's
still totally fine for white and maybe
the computer will say Oh whites just
completely equal I think from a
practical point of view that makes
whites life so much more difficult
especially if you capture on c3 then
your love for these oh wait don't you
lose material Bishop b5 check I think no
that solves that doesn't it so if you
can't take it and that he's actually
doing what I wanted with 95 but he's
doing it even better I thought I needed
to protect c3 it turns out I don't
because if you can't take it now you're
Brooke f2 is I just this is this is
super dangerous
you could even consider Bishop e4 in
some positions again not with 96 check
but I I'm with you man Wong house e3
this optimizes blacks chances
long that was a very opportunistic
player we saw him defeat being the red
wending the RAM was playing oddly in
that first round game but won't how who
won the feed HS calm grants whist in the
Isle of Man 2019 or that is a mouthful
to say if you know we didn't we didn't
want that long of a title but when you
when you spend a lot of money and it was
expensive to put your name on a feed a
Grand Prix leg
you kind of want chest comm in the title
but Isle of Man is also a great place to
visit and feed a grand swiss was
required so guess what we landed with
majestic on feed a grand swiss at the
isle of man well i think it was a
handful and well how was a handful there
because he finished in first place tied
with five in a car wanna ahead on
tiebreaks and ahead of magnus carlsen
and four five and a car wanna well the
Challenger and 2018 he has had so many
tournament successes the 2014
Sinquefield Cup chief amongst them 7o
starts that event the best results in
history better than any other I don't
think there's is there another result
that's I mean there's some comparable
ones I guess or what players dominating
their fields but I'm pretty sure I've a
no car Juana's performance rating was
the highest in history at that event
crazy stuff in that event and I remember
being there live and it was like it was
surreal watching watching that kind of
performance every commentary show with
you is surreal though though you know I
I get I get to be enjoying my job every
day let's go back over to vash nila
Rob's game the palm knee she is still
under the gun but he did play Queen b6
okay just in time the variation we
predicted up to this point was on the
board so we don't need to back up
Queen a1 is a new move and makes sense
because you're threatening Queen a3
check we've highlighted that the Queen
at night the best dynamic duo since
Batman and Robin wrench in Hess you
can't spell chess without Hess
I'm just trying to get there it is I'm
trying to smile all day thank you
I mean you know you've been doing a fine
job and trying too hard
does the frost op all right you're right
all right we need three friends
threatens mate but the problem for black
is dealing with that is not so easy
right if you go Queen b3 is a seven okay
maybe that's the idea if you can
sacrifice a seven you get perpetual
check ideas Robert let's analyze that
but I sort of point out there's another
issue of e-cigs right any moment that
ponds not just helping to check me it
might become a queen you have to be
careful apparently apparently six is too
fast I don't really really care for a
computer but apparently apparently there
was no reason to rush it so let's think
but I do like your point that at some
point Eddie the Eagle is more than a
binder right he wants to Eddie Eddie
becomes Elizabeth Queen Ani eight
you
what do you do here in a position with
the Queen on b3 you can't take a seven
because of Perpetual z--
these sixes may be premature but he
played Queenie six Danny oh so we have
live action maybe there was just a move
like going after the pawn or something
okay so Queenie six was played another
creative way to try to get out the King
but I actually think again 93 is a
simple response at a lot of positions it
hits d5 at threatens f5 at guards chief
for
but the downside is maybe the Queen
comes h3 and okay yeah that's okay so
that's not good here
I think I'll play Knight g3 and the
essential point is he's not unhappy
giving up the f4 pawn because Knights
are amazing defenders that should be
stated a knight let's say a knight on G
three King on g2 the night just defense
all these important squares around the
King and makes a Queen's life very
difficult but use only this pawn I guess
you get a seven in the end I'll gladly
take that a7 pawn okay my my my II I
said II six pawn my pony it's going to
get to e6 soon where it serves as both a
potential Queen enjoy the ride you got
to stop and look around every once in a
while life moves pretty fast you might
miss it i I just saw a succession and
it's really weird seeing Alan ruck as
like you know a 63 year old man or
however one of the greatest characters
of all time
Rudy anyway we've got okay you make a
great point about 93 because it wasn't
my first instinct I wanted to stay
aggressive but and by the way is there
still Queen h3 let's just look at that
real quick what's the difference now I
guess is what you said is the knight is
just such a brilliant defender wowzers
yep this is so this is so key and I
think for for viewers watching how to
convert a spicy endgame like this where
you know you're better you know you're
winning or your opponent's not gonna
roll over right and you don't want to
allow any outside perpetual bringing the
knight safely back to your king often
the right idea and
it just it's a great mood
like you said so pesky just guarding
everything you take a pond like this and
you take here and then all you have is
one check right the night just it guards
f1 that guards h1 guards h5
I mean something is going to fall for
black probably the d5 pawn and after
that does en D pawns passers just
too much keep the night around the king
suddenly preventing perpetual check is
super easy barely an inconvenience not a
problem at all when your nights around
your King I love it
no I mean I think we're about to see a
time this candidates tournament
continues to not disappoint right I mean
there's nothing about this event that
has not been drama billed and again even
even in the environment which of course
is a lot to talk about and we have been
and whether the events should even be
going and of course if it was to stop we
would all be fully supportive but while
we are chess fans we will enjoy the
chests that has been amazing on the
board and tournament that might just get
even closer
what's amazing is if somebody else gets
a decisive point Robert you could see a
very jam-packed leaderboard you could
see two people tie the top somebody at
four points maybe Grichuk converts on
his game is black no he got away with oh
why did I say that
right as I say that why do I ever think
that Geary is gonna not I mean I guess
he did one yesterday hashtag for Gary I
mean Chris trickster on all his games
do that so what happened here we were
liking I guess Gary rightfully doesn't
get too ambitious he just plays Bishop
III stopping your whole Bishop c5 idea
and it was just going to be equal ever
since
yeah it's one of those positions is
probably slightly slightly better for
black but realistically they're gonna
make a draw anyway so might as well not
drag it out and yeah sasha was seven
draws seven draw sasha was his nickname
in high school
that's what I was about to say but I
knew you were gonna say it so I don't
have the floor hey using jokes way more
than they were ever meant to be used as
my thing not yours
and you're late buddy is that also your
high school nickname get back in your
lane Dan yeah give it back in your lane
Dan and I'm using more jokes and never
need to be used dad
no that was my spiritual Native American
name past life memory that's a different
thing
okay on to a different game by the way
Knight g3 played by Maxime he continues
to impress great chess today and
then yeah this is gonna be I mean now
there's threats of about five everybody
the king the king is completely safe
over here with this brilliant night
retreat that Robert found before Mac
seemed dead and we think that we will
have two leaders after today
yeah I'm sure Maxime saw it immediately
and he was just you know trying to check
out other lines happens very regularly
at the highest level these guys see
ideas very quickly but then they're
thinking 8 moves down the road what what
is that position like how do I evaluate
it right but this is not hard to
evaluate and it's gonna be a hard pill
to swallow for Jana Palma she who looked
like he was just cruising in this
tournament 3 wins out of six games no
losses but as he looks to suffer his
first defeated Danny I want to ask you a
question actually how did how to say
young upon Nicky I feel like I'm saying
it the same way you are but everyone
yells at me and Chad say you're not
punishing I'm not doing this right now
but what I was going to ask you was a
relevant question yeah was that if you
were gonna have four and a half at a
seven would you rather have three wins
and a loss or two wins and no losses
right so if maxime win this game he will
have two wins and no losses and that
would be Yuans first loss with his three
wins so which would you rather have you
know okay I think ultimately it's you
know we're reading a little bit in
between the lines and and that's our job
as commentators because I think the best
players in the world have short-term
memory loss and that's their job to so I
don't know if it really matters but as
far as a momentum indicator I would
still say that I would take not having a
loss two draws I'm sorry two wins and
all the restaurant know you don't have
you don't even have any bad feelings now
you put the pom mushy in a position to
be psychologically struggling a little
bit right he's had a loss he's gotten
outplayed from start to finish in a game
and that doesn't feel good man
right Plus Maxime almost had three wins
I mean he's had some great chance he had
a great chance against grishnack in that
game and again scoreboard is what
matters
almost doesn't count but I think from a
momentum perspective while it has been
all all the man with the man bone as
I've said but you definitely changed the
story line if Maxime gets this victory
here I think I think you prefer his
route to four and a half over having a
loss what do you think well I think one
of the tiebreaks is number of wins so
I'd much rather have three wins and a
loss well well thanks for letting me go
on and on and then just burst my bubble
let's bring up the daily quest
speaking of bubbles burst a time let me
let you be on camera while you smile
how's that I have that I have the
controls that you don't okay we asked a
question to all of you earlier when
trailing in a tournament at what point
should you consider games to be a
must-win Robert and I did a lot of prep
yesterday and evaluated that the last
time Maxine was in a must-win situation
against Jana pom Nishi he actually
played 1.d4 did we feel that he would
play it again today does he feel in a
must-win apparently not he played 1.e4
Coralville for three says no just try to
relax keep things as simple play your
natural game and hope for the best okay
that sounds like the worst advice ever
okay no kidding at CTP and a little when
you're playing opponents ahead ahead of
you especially the leader I don't even
know what that answers
the day become wet age oh oh wait okay
you treat us it must win when you're
playing opponents ahead of you
especially the leader okay so he's
saying yes this is a must-win whoa
okay you read this one okay you would
have me read a woman that's from one
cool dude after a defeat the next game
is always a must-win transposing into
complicated rarely seen positions can be
a great way to surprise your opponent I
mean that's what MDL did right with his
opening today he went back to the French
and we're back in 84 right but he he put
the French that elects anko played
against Brian DePalma shoot two rounds
ago right well then he switched it up
with his h4 h5 making Yuans life
difficult well infinite said after
seeing the French one time against Alex
anko he didn't think he on upon me she
would would play for it again but he did
right again if you're just joining us
will bring up the analysis board and
give you the quick TL DR in this game in
terms of how we got here the the main
thing that surprised us is he repeats a
French look no hands
the moves are going by themselves
magically you're a wizard Danny I'm your
wizard ever so he plays a French but he
plays the widower French here repeating
what he did against alec Senko and maybe
now regretting it Maxime apparently was
ready for it all these moves were played
very quickly by the Frenchman and while
King f8 was the first novelty really the
first novelty in terms of how the
players handled it to us was this move
right here I'll pause it with Queen D 1
when Maxime played this move was when
Yann first started to think neppo found
all the best moves according to our
world champion and super GM analyst that
was awesome having Vishnu invented with
us and I think we may have one of them
coming back so don't go anywhere but
really it was up until this moment here
when he took a ton of time and sometimes
that happens when you spend the most
time Robert you play your worst move and
this was not the right idea according to
everybody it kind of not just the wrong
move but also the thing about c4 Robert
is it it was a move that eliminated what
seemed to be one of the crucial ideas
for black in the structure keep the
lights cores open for the Queen right so
the move itself wasn't good but also the
idea I think was was the first sign that
things were going wrong for yelling yeah
an MV L is brilliant I mean if we go
forward a couple moves to this route
before exchange sacrifice yeah that was
just you know you had that one teed up
and just really really smart chess here
and look at what Yann does he went
knight c6 and then Amelia goes oh wait
Knight back to e7 doesn't even take the
rook yeah that he was attacking so
brilliant play by Maxime and I this is a
really fantastic game I'm sorry to force
and assuming he converts it will just
quickly get you here to the live
position so you can see it again 93
Queen G for likely will just be met by
King g2 and as Robert has said the
knight defense the King well NV L may be
on his way to converting a victory but
we bring back our bird's-eye view one
more time here we see the second game
that has also ended week we kind of
stopped following Dingley run and Alex
Sink oh there as the simplification was
was occurring we apologize for that for
those who were super into how to trade
into a rook ending but okay no red red
suit
not even a single letter we've got the
two games left that really matter
shave the Grove and upon Russia as well
as Caruana
versus Wang Hao and yeah all it really
matters when we do these shows is gonna
keep people focused on on the big games
and getting getting the opinions of
big-time chess players
hard to think of one better than Vichy
and on right now Vichy how you doing
thanks for joining us again thanks I was
planning to join a bit later but things
are heating up later wrapping up yep
okay so MBL first of all I mean I think
93 is very sensible under the
circumstances but let query three Jack
work
let's see let's analyze shall we
I mean I just I was having a quick nap
and then I woke up saw my phone without
Queen a3 check for that even 93 there
are only two squares right f7 and g8
well that's joking EA Rock workers some
of us have to see basic tactics this guy
anyway go ahead
so King it let's go King of seven first
heating up seven I take it 96 and f5 is
just huge
yeah that looks may be his problem is
Queenie 7 followed by some Queen g5 and
that may be a propeller
very right it looks very risky right
just to give it so many checks
yes so if I don't play a fire then maybe
I have to come back maybe I would have
to come back 93 anyway that maybe that
was his point and my point with King g8
was a very beautiful line if you go King
g8
then I go 97 check
well King at seven now at five you don't
have the e7 square
oof it's still an open question if there
is a also white could bail I mean white
can bail out between day six here yeah I
was thinking about that too and it's
queen h5 then i have queen g6 check and
exchange queens and then take on d5 and
then ii 67 wins
that's resigned ring good enough
okay so here I don't think this works
there you go back you come king of seven
then I got Knight g6 and this is the
pre-k point icons queen g4 check King f2
you don't have any further checks you
take on in the night 87
oh that's so nice you win the one
variation but I think Maxine is being
very sensible of course oh no that was a
nice line though it looks like as you
said though the critical point might
have ended up being that but if that by
looking at 796 King g8 wasn't as
convincing then right it was this move
was the key right yeah besides if in g2
Queen takes f4 white can still go Queen
a3 check if he wants if he feels that
was useful the only thing is I think
your instead of 96 and f5 I could have
gone 93 just like Maxine did
yeah after king of seven we made three
checking of seven
and the 93 and now if Quincy folk kingi
- Quinn takes a fall then I play maybe
Quinn d6 or queen takes a 7 and
it's nice that your king is pinned
against but yeah blacks position quickly
falls apart it feels like right you know
just picking off pawns and desist
it just looks huge I don't know what
what my young can try I mean King G do
h5 but I can't believe it I mean g6 like
what I can't in the main line King cheat
you here
yeah g6 is thinking but I'm really
desperately on because this feels it
just feels very wrong a g6 h5 and try to
recognition vichy right before you came
on I was saying that you know you you
and Vidhan we all were critical of Yuans
decision to place c4 do you think you
know he just totally missed this
exchange sacrifice that MBL went with
with this rook before line way back when
well I'm surprised because I don't think
it's even that well was it was an eclair
line that I'd be for a before which is
good for white wasn't so yeah we didn't
even look too much in death because we
kind of trusted
[Music]
I didn't know there was a semi clear
line I mean okay you can't take twice
obviously Queen see three wins the brook
in the end and a line we just looked at
was just be 5 and then Bishop before
with that five coming anyways you know
but here it's huge because f5 is winning
sorry right what do you I play rook
takes before Knight takes before instead
of 90 XP
a queen bee six you just play Quincy
three right probably
and again if someone is walking by the
board Vichy they start screaming
forecastles yeah I mean in the Berlin
you don't get to Qasim just because he
moved your king here we move the king
and you said it best when we were
looking at the position not few moves
before that right it looks like a fish a
random position gone wrong for black
yeah well in Fisher random you could
just Castle now instantly that's just a
fake stupid chess Stockholm bugs prevent
it you're right
well this yeah anyway no it's funny the
point it's truly that's very
did he actually play 96 f 490 yeah yeah
he went I see six and went right back
which I mean that then then that's
clearly why I think that's why Robert
asked whether you think we just and you
couldn't give white at this point
because
has all the time in the world and look
he managed we should see one in three
with it
yeah no I think he just completely
overlooked this idea because I don't
know how to justify black decided to
close down the queenside with c4 or
other than that he thought he would be
able to get his king around and be safe
but when he went knight c6 and it meets
f4 the knight back to e7 that's a really
terrible sign when you were treating
your piece to where it came from
right well yeah I think you're right
Robert this idea seems that after a
couple of wins you get euphoric and then
you have a
he says that a couple days ago hmm you
said there couple days ago the problem
with winning is you get you for it right
yeah and you have but I mean this one's
been very shaky and yeah g4
this year I had a question before and of
course the tiebreak sort of indicates
what the answer should be but imagine
there was no tiebreak based on number of
wins if you weren't going to get to ask
or would you rather houses you what it's
number of losses excuse me you you're
right you're right
my apologies I was looking at things
optimistically but number of losses is a
good chespin brain way to think of it
but would you rather in general have say
three wins and one loss or two wins and
no losses to get the same score
um well personally I'd prefer the no
losses of course but thank you that's
what I said
yeah I mean me when you lose again you
don't know that you're gonna get the
compensating women so that point it
feels really bad and
in the end I guess it doesn't really
matter but I would think that the
personal score is should be more
important than number of wins
this rule has been around for a while
and I remember after the London
candidates when we got to have ultimate
sis for the 2014 candidates
kramnik tried to stir up discussion
about looking at Ibrox thus his point
was not only
he didn't have a big problem with the
wind rule he thought winds with black
was a bit strange because so for such a
long tournament can you really doesn't
make such a big difference whether you
win with black or white but he really
thought
[Music]
is there some scenario Buchholz comes in
and I think he thought that was bizarre
and he will but basically he wanted to
have a discussion
so I remember when we got to hunt a
there was a brief discussion and what it
turned out was every single player
agreed with Kramnik in principle that
there should be he some changes but
nobody wanted to get around to it
because they were too busy thinking of
the tournament and in the end Carnac
just gave up he said it's a waste of
time nobody is going to do anything and
essentially that's what happens every
time we always discuss should we revisit
these tiebreaker rules because there are
many issues with them and yes there are
and you ask any player one month before
if he wants to spend a couple of hours
discussing this he says no I want to
prepare my openings and that's what
always happens so this thing will keep
on saying that it should be discussed
but we never will it should be imposed
by fear didn't yeah well I just don't
ask the question but I appreciate the
answer there it's always been
interesting to me thinking about the
psychology of how you get to a score and
what it's going to be but right now we
have nvl looking to get even with Jana
palma she and he'll have two wins -
yawns three which I guess bodes well for
Yuans chances but coming off a loss as
you said it's hard to rebound in general
from that at least three wins and no
loss was much better this defeat then
and with so many rounds left I I don't
mean with seven rounds left I don't
think I break my toes yet right it
should start filtering into their heads
last time with with lemon I had this big
advantage even though he caught up with
me he felt the constant pressure that if
we just drifted into a few draws and he
would have need a win at all costs and
so he started pushing a bit
yeah I don't see it happening here yet
that's what I wanted to bring her
attention sorry to the other game that
we have going on because I just that
corner of my eyes fine isn't black just
pressing here like what if I take on b2
and after King b2 of rook takes T to
check
Thanks
that move well yeah overloaded pieces
right there's a night on e3 I was just
looking at the game and I was like well
that night is kind of stuck and I don't
know how big I was gonna say is this
just oh don't don't take my bishop
yeah now we gotta keep the knight on the
board this should be pretty good drawing
chances here though I mean
no this is just a drawers okay okay so
missin maybe even Bobby I know one just
to simplify things as quickly as
possible well I I thought it was at
first times I wait there's a tactic here
looks like a blunder but maybe he's just
saying this is saying was I'm not sure
if I'm H bonus lose maybe I lose it this
way I had bail out to a drone ending and
take that
that's the case I think we're actually
closer to this looks like a draw than if
that's the case right because the rook
can't take h2 with f3 hanging how do you
deal with the pin currently if that if
that whole line doesn't yield anything
there's also g6 and tried to get GFI g4
and to defend the bishop but these are
complicated execute and if I play h3
it's impossible right
Brook f80 and then if GFI like and in
fact I can already start repeating with
94 93 it's just a wrong
sorry assuming you were taken see we do
that we are okay one check which is also
not very convincing now I think
black should take cb2 intothe
how it seems to be doing yeah no sexy
that's happened and I got so excited by
the tactic then I you know forgot that
after all is said and done it's just fun
and liquid into a drawn end game yeah
taking h2 not an option then that's a
way to lose the position so taking c2
again everybody
there's a nice tactic but after King
takes Bishop before check nothing but a
draw thing as they say White's easily
throwing in a game like this even though
down upon
all right so it looks like it's possible
dinner today the only game with the only
game with the decisive result was the
one that had our attention throughout as
we see there on the live board we've
already got
while I was trying one else flying
we'll keep the light board real quick
just I want to keep a spine that because
we might be moments away from a result
there between MBL and Nepal menisci
because the Queen on d6 is crushing but
let's look a little bit of h5 here that
long how not giving up on winning just
yet
so how how is he gonna try to win this
yeah let's say I go look at fake
exactly the winning plan
David
you're gonna 91 me
five you just go 91 and yes
we call this gearing
well here you if you wanted you could
play Rudy too right I would just go h3
and ask you what you're doing
we reset it in this one should be a draw
even going for that
h3 and
g-force not really an option anyway
maybe he wants to go king e5 and come
fall here for
well it's fine
the TV actually has gained anything if
he plays if I go hench for after h5 what
is black actually going to do is it
going to play up taxi to
ah now the Jackson Kings II do
before indeed to whichever side Kingi to
and I'm just in time with King getting
to g3 protecting my palm just other
words like I just came to have formed a
bishop day for you might lose the h-bomb
yeah talking still drawing
but I like the effort I think we're
gonna get a little more time on this one
let's bounce over bring both both of our
full focus over here any any last
chances we're gonna see so there's no
threat of East six here for vache The
Grove so where's the win
I guess you're just wanting to take
default yes I'm currently de Conde file
with your King on the aid if you move
your king to either side I will check
and take to defy with the result that
your king will be on d8 anyway so
there's not even that glimmer of hope
right
and I gotta move that's it
I get the feeling we're about to see a
result hit this relay live from Russia
the dgt board giving us a 1-0 if I had
to guess because the pond Russia is uh
there's no moose right yeah that night
on g3 there enough cannot be said about
that night wasn't a my easing defender
yeah I just such it just covers
everything and there's no way to get any
series of checks and well the e-pawn so
past the d5 on the d5 pawn excuse me
following this is just a walk in the
park for MBL again I have to say my
Queenie a3 may or may not have worked
but I was immense value ninety-three is
such a little move wrong to even go down
any other Road well how do you balance
that when you're converting games like
be the pressure you put on yourself to
go for the forcing Queen a3 kind of
knockout blow versus just recognizing
from a practical perspective
ninety-three eliminates perpetual checks
and this should be enough like is there
like just a practical advice you would
say like you should just settle on 93 or
you say you should always go for seeing
if the concrete line wins first before
settling on a move like 93
generally the good technique is to make
93 without thinking you see one way to
win and it's simple and whence then it's
the Reds over a
I've often seen Magnus do this he'll
take some plus seven position and he'll
liquidate down to a plus one sly endgame
and then win that the next 20 moves
because he he is lower the chances of
tying something going wrong and that's
far more important being quick
all right this very good technique the
only thing sorry is that sometimes if
you are trying very hard not to
calculate it could be a sign that you're
drifting but that's clearly or not
happening I mean Maxie must have seen
that it's Queen exits way to d6 and this
position looks horrible right away right
well good advice on the good technique
of 93 and eliminating counter chances
we're being told that probably my
prediction that we're about to see a 1-0
from the dgt relay is correct neppo is
not even looking at the board on sight
and frustrated and shaking his head so
obviously it he's gonna have to recover
from this with a guy like neppo who can
be very shrieky you said in round 1 when
he won a brilliant game this she that
you know the guys the guys talent has
never been questioned right what he's
capable of as far as his talent is there
but consistency has always been the
thing that people wondered if he would
find right and and not be his own worst
enemy at times in self-destruct so with
how well he's played maybe six of the
best chess games in a row now with this
loss what would be the would-be chess
coach Vishwanath on anons advice or
neppo psychologically well you know for
me it's it's Groundhog Day for what he
did in st. Louis he he started with
minus one against me what is way back to
plus two that's three wins
in a tournament which was not very
high-scoring by the way we fall back to
+2 and then he he lost to Maxine and he
lost by just blitzing out a move and
then putting the move in the wrong order
he put the knight in the wrong square
and the black could just capture a pawn
and that was it
so yes exactly the sort of game his
coach foster feared might happen and
what can you do you have to nothing to
be done now and I mean I'm sure he
really feels like kicking himself be
done today
no stingy father's happened he's made a
move but I don't think it changes
anything stylistically and I just don't
see what's happening yeah no it's just
it's over or the line you already said
at some point taking d5 but he just
takes the pawn instead but don't even
think six immediately and I think he's
he's not gonna take there maybe because
there's Queeny for that step aside yeah
but after a head your back and just go
g7 a new queen I like it yeah and when
you move your queen to threaten my mind
I play six and that's it's just over
wherever you go to stop g8 I'll play six
especially you talked about the sink
filled cup a little bit of deja vu for
neppo to lose to MBL in the middle in a
crucial round in the middle of a
tournament stylistically are they're
sometimes just players that are sure are
tough I mean coming into this this game
here we can maxime overall in his career
as +6 against nepo +5 in classical and
if with this game he would be back to +6
in classical is it is there something
that certain styles of certain players
that you know frustrate a particular
player do you is there a little bit of
that with with Maxime and neppo you know
I hadn't noticed it and I wasn't
particularly aware of it but I mean six
losses will leave a scar somewhere so
I'm sure
Napo feels it much more strongly
sometimes from the outside you don't
know to say I mean I know my own writing
is people and so but the or against
between Maxime and neppo I was not aware
of well the game is officially over
whether we really see where it's coming
from the 1-0 has been relayed whether
there is a stylistic issue or not
between these two players all that
matters is Maxime Boucher magrav has
gotten a another win against Yonder pom
Nishi he ties him atop the leaderboard
in the standings and we have we have
lift-off Vichy we're gonna have drama in
the back half of this event this is
gonna be an exciting I mean this is
wonderful fans because two guys on +2
and
and actually we shouldn't forget all the
people on 50% are now half a point Allah
said to the leaders that's right it
happened to matically right so that
suddenly means we're not looking just at
two house rates right someone could
easily slip into plus one and then it
becomes very tricky if everyone these
two guys have to keep looking back so
it's a vicious I have a question for you
about you know we keep trying a style
and we see that these two players are
ahead of the pack right now how do they
match up in your opinion against Magnus
Carlsen because Jana Palma she has a
plus score against Magnus which is
surprising to most people that anyone
has a score this point against Magnus
Carlsen but what do you make of their
chances either of these players are
really anyone in the field against
Magnus Carlsen
let's start with Jana I think
it was very nice that he had a +4 score
at some point I mean I remember watching
this game in London where Magnus really
outplayed him completely and then he
just managed to take some wild tactical
short out calculate Magnus Merion Magnus
blundered some little detail and boom
game is over
and I thought he unspoiled last year in
Croatia by losing to Magnus
attain again he really did not make
loose I mean at some point just of
all right I mean maybe he kept pushing I
don't know a bit longer but somehow it
just ended with Magnus getting a nice
tactical shot so Magnus had one of these
closed positions where he just had to
sit wait and then suddenly there was
this one chance to break and boom it was
over but still having a plus coder is
helpful I think for Maxine it's harder
because it's not just a plus score it's
big isn't it I would guess at least plus
5 or plus 6 for Magnus to DL yeah here's
a Stefan size vote for score yeah last
year itself I remember 3 wins it was
grandpa influence and Croatia yep so 3 3
wins and just last year and they've been
wins before as well so yeah when my when
Maxim one incident Louis it was a big
relief for him because he was already -
fall down at that point then he lost a
further three after that so right now
it's tough but again he's the last
minute man he is just turning up
everywhere at the last minute and then
and during Wally his his optimism and
everything will allow him to put up a
big fight he is eight when he if he wins
this after having not expected to be in
the candidates and then he faces Magnus
he'll be a happy man he'll he'll do all
the work he has to do he you know him
who everything he needs to do and we
don't need to doubt his willingness to
put in the effort so yeah this he I just
looked it up Magnus is plus 8 equal to
18 draws but in their heads head matchup
last eight okay so plus 9 and minus one
right yeah yeah but at the same time you
all ask I'll ask the same question this
way is because of what we saw in the
last World Championship between Caruana
and Carlsen and essentially what in
hindsight was kind of a pre
predetermined path for Magnus to get to
get two tiebreaks in terms of the
advantage he felt overall against
Fabiano and rapid and blitz that's not
something that I think Magnus would have
in his mind against either neppo or MBL
and do you think that poses a bit of a
different challenge to Carlsen in a
match setting where you know that I
named exhibit do you do you think that
do you think you would rather get
Caruana again or one of these new guys
nepo or MBL
well with Magnus I think last year there
was a real question whether he even
wanted to be there he seemed to
not be very happy and then at some point
in the middlee
at least at the strange situation of
watching him that he was willing to play
very sharp and interesting chess with
black but with white somehow he kept on
holding back maybe this was an effect
from the Kuryakin match because when you
fall one point behind it except for a
while
[Music]
I don't see Magnus as being particularly
shaken by the prospect of meeting either
of these guys but both of them are
strong players who can beat him on a
good day
have to be have to prepare well but
people are doing that
well definitely appreciate your thoughts
because yeah well there's hardly anybody
out there other coke people who have the
same world champion to experience as you
do but you know it's very interesting
thinking of stylistic matchups and who
is capable of really competing with
Magnus Carlsen at this stage because his
rating has been a number one in the
world for 10 years now but then you find
out the young eponymous use the plus
score and I was like wait oh I didn't
realize then I guess some people are
tough matchups even from acting
stylistically Yanis the more difficult
player for him here because he is much
more predictable than Emery Ellis
I think Magnus has the ability to pin
MVL down and mal is already a fairly
predictable player but Magnus is able to
move at least so far he gives the
evidence he gives the impression of
having control in his games against MDL
I think yan is much more unpredictable
for Magnus but the problem for yan is
there is this
like tendency to be very vulnerable at
times but on his birthday
I think he's a bigger threat allistic
will obviously get your thoughts on
these two guys as the event goes on
especially if it becomes clear that
either one of them or another person
gets involved in the challenge because I
get questions in my head like with that
kind of time to prepare what Maxime do
the unthinkable and think of something
completely surprising right not be the
creature of habit we know he is in the
Grune Feldon in the night or would you
advise as a coach to stick with your gun
Joe I think there's so much you could
talk about right in a match setting
that's a little bit different than
anything that they've faced before but
what do you thought the beauties and
matches is you have a fixed opponent
right and you have a target and you have
many months and you know you can get a
big team and do some work
so if you use it as a chance to expand
your horizons and chests and you know
you look forward to it and you're
grateful for the chance and it's and you
do things you never done but often but
what do you disproportionately in my
view should do it well officially this
game has now been drawn it is in the
books which means that you were with us
for the whole finisher of issue which we
greatly appreciate that's that's how it
comes down everybody in round seven
three draws one win apparently be the
the only win that really mattered Maxine
Bosh neethu Grove takes home the full
point ties Jana pom Nishi atop the
leaderboard we will be back with our
final thoughts we're gonna say goodbye
to Vichy right now Robert and I will
wrap things up with just outcomes
coverage here in just a few minutes
[Music]
you
and welcome back everybody to what was
an incredible round seven here just
outcomes coverage of the 2020 feat a
candidates tournament is not over yet
Grand Master Robert Hess and I were
gonna dive into some detail post game
coverage here talk to you a little bit
about this matchup we predicted would be
huge and it didn't disappoint and maybe
even be biding our time a little bit for
an interview so stay on the edge of your
seat there we may or may not be joined
by someone sometimes you have to stick
around you don't know the ending so
stick around Robert we do know we had
some answers to the Davey question yep
when trailing in a tournament at what
point should you consider games to be a
must-win obviously the storyline was
that Maxime Vashta the Graaf was down a
point coming in and how would you
mentally prepare for that let me just
ask you Robert we can take our time here
did you consider this a must-win for MDL
we already know what happened he won so
if it was he went big but your thoughts
on the David question especially given
the stats that these two players had
coming in and the research we did about
that yeah I think that for Maxime he
absolutely needed to win this game was
mandatory if he wants to be the one to
play magnus carlsen for a world
championship title and you know how do
you prepare mentally I think his
preparation was excellent the opening
that he got from the white side of a
French I could maybe say that Yann
Lost's can move one
it's interesting right because as we
bring up the the breakdown we did know
there the this is a fairly summarized
version this is beyond the Cliff Notes
version of some of the takeaways we had
and we'll show that on the board here so
if you're really interested in diving
into the X's and O's stick with us and
learn something but we the reason we
predicted that maybe d4 would be played
and even if he for having played 10
times we just didn't think y'all would
go for the French I even posted some of
our research on reddit right before the
round just hanging out and I just I
thought if he four was played maybe e5 I
would have even thought maybe a
caro-kann but instead Yan goes for the
French and clearly right now has to be
just greatly regretting it because
Maxime was in control of this game from
start to finish without a doubt and
because of that he is now tied Yann atop
the leaderboard here for the candidates
yeah and we both see Yan is being quite
an aggressive player somebody who likes
having attacking possibilities and
countered chances and the position he
got he was always the one being pressed
he made moves like rook g8 to HEA King
yet to f8 earlier in Kiev a back to e
that's not the type of game that Yan
DePalma she likes to play so he was not
in his element as we see the leaderboard
and we just saw there that Yan now is
tied with Maxime but surely Grove and
yep that's you know student start go
ahead no are you guys that you made a
great point Irish guide to it like these
moves rookie a rookie like okay this was
maybe still part of the plan but then
that's the way the game went on his
uncomfortable behavior was reflected
perhaps most clearly by the clock right
and again that's not that's not us
drawing storylines we've talked about a
lot but that's because it's a it's a
real take away you consistently have
when we've seen these players play our
entire lives and you know that when Yan
is playing well Robert on Form
he's usually also playing very fast the
guys memory is incredible his
calculation skills are on the level of
being a genius right and when he's
confident he doesn't need to take time
right but the fact that he slowed down
so much was really indicative that he
wasn't comfortable right so already puts
himself in a tough spot and then as we
said in the critical moment here when
everything about the position suggested
maintain the tension
bring a little bit of pressure perhaps
on the light squares we analyzed this
for a long time with our with our
co-hosts c4 was played and even if it
doesn't immediately become winning for
what you and I am from a practical point
of view I'll give you credit now I
wouldn't say in the middle the game
because it always sounds like we're
we're being biased if I say our behind
the scenes stuff but I can tell you guys
we went to break and Robert said Danny
Mac seems gonna win this game right here
when it was still it was 50/50 he just
said like c4 is just not good and Robert
was like MBL was going to win this game
I'm calling it now and the D dictated
the rest of the game right he dictated
it I'll go ahead and honestly there was
absolutely no bias in the statement it
just you know I'm impressed on both
these players but this is not at all
really any one style to have the black
side disposition but I mentioned Sergei
crack and earlier he's the type of
player who fends these positions off and
is able to secure half points even full
points from positions that look as bad
as this but I mean knight c6 played in
the night back to e7 is very modular
design knew you were gonna want to talk
about that again this was this was one
of those moments right oh just a
brilliantly exchanged sacrifice and I
think that's what Yann completely missed
is you know he went c4 to start trying
to get his King to the Queen side and
safeguard everything but just not caring
about material he's not a materialistic
guy he's Mexican brush of the graph goes
for half four and it's just like so this
right here again right would you know
the game within the game that you know
it's always easier for us to sound like
it you know we knew when we were talking
on hindsight but we were calling for it
in the middle of game that you know the
time management was off that was at
least clear that yawn was uncomfortable
and there's no debating when you seen I
see 1697 you and I say this a lot one of
those moves is a mistake no matter it's
under it's undeniable right either the
move you're about to play is a mistake
in 97 or the move you played before was
a mistake when you do those things now
there are rare exceptions where you you
know you induce a weakness or something
but for the most part in a critical game
like this it was very clear that the
wheels were about to come off you and I
were already calculating these forest
lines that started here with the bishop
relocation and pretty much that entire
thing came on came to be right the
bishop relocated to undermine the knight
here which would allow g4 to be
devastating and
and that was exactly kind of how the
west was won here and then I'm gonna go
to that final critical moment not just
that the the very accurate Knight g3 not
Queen takes f5 but then taking the pawn
and coming back to g3 right as vichy
said this was the sign of great
technique yeah an excellent move just
making sure that you're safeguarding
your King and this she said Magnus
Carlsen does all the time he has a
winning position but simplifying into
something that you know is just easy for
you versus maybe the computer says
screaming at you +8 but you have to find
a sequence of only moves and that's very
difficult territory to be in so kudos to
Maxime for just retreating and he
converted this very smoothly and show
everybody ways that could go wrong
vicious Queen a three move wasn't
necessarily wrong at all but it we
wanted to show one of the key points was
a line that looks very good to come in
with check and advance aggressively is
where you can go wrong where somebody a
simple move Queen e7 and you see why
that evaluation bar has settled a 50%
there's no way to properly deal with
threats of Queen g5 or Queen h4 when
you've overextended and allowed a
perpetual so that's a really good
example of how it could go wrong for for
white but it didn't Maxime so on top of
his game plays Knight g3 here the point
as Robert called is the knight is just
the best defender in chess around the
King there are no perpetual x' but
Maxine was able to be more aggressive
with the Queen again the night just
guards all the key squares you can give
one check but that'll often be your last
so eventually Queen d6 comes in
apparently on spent more than five
minutes on the clock here basically not
looking at the board Robert from our
on-site team kind of informing us he was
shaking his head ultimately settled on
g5 but then resigns after g7 for good
reason you can't deal with the Queen in
any way but this and E six probably
among other things as its game over so
obviously it's the biggest game of the
tournament so far in what is the biggest
tournament of the year before the World
Championship Robert so we're going over
it in great detail for a good reason
your final thoughts again here and I'll
ask you to play the role of chess coach
for Yun upon me she because we asked the
vichy and you know he said it this is
tough
right the psychology of losing this game
what would be your thoughts and how
would you give advice to what has been
the tournament leader and now is no
longer alone at the top well he gets the
white pieces in his next game right so
he just needs to settle down and he has
the Russians coming it was contagious
he's playing out you just wait no he
gets it
what are you playing the first round he
wanting it's a nice Giri it's why he
goes in each Giri then he plays Grisha
can elect saenko so you know he eat the
white piece tomorrow just play your
chest you've been in excellent shape
don't pay attention to standings right
now you know of course Maxime is tied
and has the tiebreaker based on
head-to-head result but a lot will
happen in the final seven games so I
think Yann has been in fine form
throughout the event the French was a
bad opening decision again yep Maxime I
believe and I think young will be fine I
really do it's he's the right ship I
think you just touched on the best way
to psychologically heal yourself they're
just kind of blaming it on like one
decision it I mean that in a good way
right because you know when you're on I
wear this a lot like you know sports and
chess is psychology sometimes getting
yourself to focus on what you can
control focus on the good things right
because that brings out more good things
and you just said it right Robert you
said the French was a bad decision and I
think sometimes you look back and you
say that at this level and again forget
the French haters let it go guys Robert
I have fun we know the French can be a
very good solid opening teaches a lot of
good positional stuff to players my
producer plays the French I recommended
it for as good positional stuff but at
the highest levels of preparation the
French can be dubious often when these
guys right I mean and that's what we saw
here
Maxime was never not in control of this
game and I think if you psychologically
tell yourself Robert why did I do that
I just won't make decisions like that
again get back to playing the chess I've
been playing it kind of allows you to
just let it all go on one decision and
then get back to being positive which is
where you want your head to be yeah I
think that is a great summary you can
blame it on your opening rather than on
your play and yes of course
yawns play was far from perfect today
but it was a symptom of a
you're diseased in a sense he just
wasn't comfortable with the position
that he got and who is going to be
comfortable when you have a king on a
fait
rock on g8 you're stuck you're trying to
find any semblance of counterplay and
you're not getting it so then you try to
lash out over there on the Queen side
and you're like wait a second material
is unimportant here comes an attack and
you're just really back against the wall
the entire game
it wasn't eons game forget about it move
on you've shown great class great chess
throughout the first half of the
candidates and if you asked yourself
you're young the polishing I think this
is how I'd altima to try to frame it if
you said hey you're gonna +2 after seven
games and you're gonna be tied only with
Maxine but Sheila grab you would take
that in a heartbeat
so looking bigger picture you're still
having an excellent tournament there's
still seven rounds left just don't play
the French defense again if you're a
plant like if you play Fabiano Caruana
with the black pieces did that already
happen or did you know what no he had
black against Fabio yeah that game
already happened that's the type person
I would never recommend playing the
French against cuz I listicle II it's a
poor choice it's but one of his second
says lay near Dominguez Perez who's the
I call him the leading French killer I
don't know I don't know if he's still a
second because there has been like
changing up in the team Fabi
okay but okay no great well well said
and again I think that you know both of
us kind of taken the natural coach role
but also it will be a psychological
storyline will continue to come back to
so for good reason and if time will tell
only one more day will tell round eight
is tomorrow and on that note let's start
previewing all the pairings starting
with a battle of countryman right there
at the top the Wang Hao and Dingley Ren
faced off and Game one
Bingley Ren lost with the white pieces
now Wang Hao gets the white pieces and
what what a if you had told Wang Hao
he'd go to AU against Dingley rent
coming in he might he has a chance to do
that tomorrow he certainly does and
Bingley Ren is not in good shape he is
not playing anywhere close to his best
chess where as well I was impressed me
with the black piece against Fabiano
Caruana in no trouble today whatsoever
in fact for a moment
look like Fabiana was the one who had to
be careful he was he split the point but
Wang Hao in good form now remains an
even score three and a seven still has a
chance he's only one point behind the
leaders and our next pairing to preview
is maybe the biggest one as far as where
our focus will be obviously yun upon me
she has has some things to figure out
Robert and I talking about maybe what
the right psychological approach would
be to kind of forget this game and and
trying to get yourself focus you know
you get the white pieces you also want
with black so what you're saying the two
guys repeated walkout one with black in
round one Jana ponder she broke one with
black in round one now he'll get the
white pieces against the nice giri and
like you said robert that's uh
that's what you got to focus on focus on
your next battle and in each gear is in
shaky form because he did win that game
that Skrillex anko but that was a
fortunate win all things considered and
then today against Kershaw
he got nothing of note with the white
pieces and almost found himself in some
trouble before simplifying and agreeing
to a drop but that's a tough matchup for
Geary Yan will look to strike and of
course Bhavana Caruana
is taking on Maxine in the next round
that will be a huge game for the
standings our new leader
co-leader but leader basically tiebreak
this far is Maxime Mozilla Grove to
remind everybody Maxime voce the graph
had the white piece obviously in round 1
which is how this whole thing works it's
a double round-robin so the colors flip
which means that Maxine will then take
on the second move there against the
American who you mentioned Anna fury in
shaky form I think the same could be
said or who many people believe to be
the pre tournament favorite Fabiano
Caruana hasn't quite found himself yet
the back half of the tournament does
give him white right so to start off so
he'd be looking to make a move there's
no time better than ever if you're
priming a Caruana you get to play one of
the leaders you get the white pieces
almost to omotte you could almost call
that a must-win for him he's gonna have
to really try to come after Maxime
tomorrow yeah and the last mention we
have here is Kirill saenko taking on
alexander gurko Risha can even score
seven drawers alex anko minus two two
losses five draws and with the white
pieces he would look to continue is a
streak of not losing games but I mean I
think we're shook you have to say some
chances and elects anko when I saw him
with white against young the palm sheet
he looked a little shaky in that game he
was spending a lot of time as Grushenka
always does so in some way similar
players here who shook the stronger of
the two he needs to make his mark and I
think route 8 is the chance that he has
to take if he is going to compete for
first place well here's a chance we're
gonna have to take catch-up with the one
and only Maxime Vashta the Groth who
just got one of the one of the biggest
wins of maybe a maybe your career
magazine congratulations on a huge game
and how are you feeling after after
today's battle
he's frozen vaccine Kevin what's up dude
I'm doing good I see iMac seems frozen
[Laughter]
fun today
we've had a lot of fun with you today
apparently over there in the in the
french-language stream you had a lot of
viewers there he is there's Maxime
what's up dude
here's the connection was working oh
nice fine up country that is his
high-tech way of ignoring you if you did
want to talk to is unstable so Maxine
like I said if you don't if you didn't
want to talk to me you don't have to
come up no jokes if you appreciate it
well I mean you're kind of breaking up
side don't you what you say maybe it's
for the best a huge wind today Maxime
congratulations how are you feeling
right now
like I get I got to get out of here
apparently everything Maxine just just
talked for like a minute straight and
tell us how you're feeling after maybe
the biggest victory in your career
[Music]
kevin has a nice feeling right now for
the biggest win of his career
Maxime is feeling fantastic you know
he's being having a good time in the
gutter Robert I don't know I think he's
back I think when I talk he's coming
back so maybe I will ask a maxim how I'm
feeling
in Ekaterinburg
after the best win of your career
awkward silence and the cleavage Lifeson
[Laughter]
busy changing networks basically hey you
already sound better so they they have a
secret they have a secret network that
they've now let you on
I love this this is amazing because
Danny usually you're the one who plates
people speechless and right now you're
just completely speechless you don't
know what to do you don't know what to
say there's nothing in your control they
can make us any different so let's talk
to Kevin for a second so Kevin
I have a question Robert do you guys yo
and why did you what did you think about
the choice of Nepal Miyagi to play the
French against the French yeah we just
got done talking about for a while I
think you know how we feel about that
just poor decision vaccines huge win
today congratulations how are you
feeling after this of course it was a
crucial game I thought like I mean win
was not vital but very appreciated let's
say were you surprised by your decision
to play the French at the board a little
bit but at the same time we had played
against Carroll in the tournament so I
had to be ready for it in hindsight is
2020 but I mean I really was very
critical of his decision to play the
French especially given the position
that you had the rook for him the rook
on G the King on f8 never felt like they
could coordinate during the game did you
think that it was still a very tough
task or did you feel like you always had
the advantage and were confident
throughout I thought that was always
better and I was very happy to find this
exchange sacrifice for instance
which is essentially forced him to go
back to e7 and then I could work out my
plan with Bishop Swan and Bishop III but
what I wouldn't have been so critical of
his decision to place the French
considering that you know in 2019 I was
discipline it takes d5
interesting
last time you guys had a French was in
the Paris Grantchester a rapid and you
played this advanced line with Knight f3
and Queen takes d4 wait no that was
comic-con
c6 e 5 c5 I mean II foresee 60-45 e5 c5
yeah yeah yeah okay yeah yeah I I guess
I know the last time we played the
French I think was in 2004 2003 included
that game wrong today
so then you were really surprised to see
the French I guess from that I mean you
said he played against Alex anko but you
were not expecting it you were expecting
maybe 185 but most X is a night off but
[Music]
before if I was an option and if we six
was definitely an option because very
often in candidates when someone plays
an opening he plays it for the whole
tournament
right well some players seem to mix and
match but of course your experience will
tell you that what players are doing but
Maxime you know as much as you said it
wasn't vital or absolutely necessary to
get this win here were you nervous going
into this game knowing just what was at
stake and you know how you could shake
up the tournament standings you'd be
honest with us right
oh yeah but I don't feel nervous it's
only halftime so if I start being really
nervous now I mean and I think you know
the important thing is to be fresh and I
think that the main difference in my
play compared to the end of 2019 I was
just playing non-stop and not feeling
fresh at all and now if it fresh I feel
I feel ready to play games against these
guys go ahead Kevin yeah you you feel
really relaxed I mean was it to relief
for you to be in the county dice because
I never saw you so fresh and so relaxed
during the tournament like like you're
just feeling happy now
I just wanted to know if that something
that your mindset change does it was
like some life objective oh I don't know
how to call it to be in the county dice
and now you you got relief no I don't
think so I think it's mostly because I
got a big break and of course even
though I didn't have much time I did
prepare more carefully for for the
candidates once I knew I was in and with
help of my my team and so what that is
my team is doing a great job so far so I
like Morris caught up with everyone in
terms of openings despite having very
little time and and then I got good
positions and I think it helps you know
when you have good positions and you're
you're in good shape minutes I don't
think it's about nerves here I was gonna
give credit to the rest you got hanging
out with Robert house in New York that's
what I was gonna say yeah that's the
that's all the fresh you needed
exactly like also I think it was the
last vacations we were getting in a
while Kevin you want to share with
Maxime the hype over there from
obviously the community by supporting
him right we know he's gotten a lot of
fans on Ches calm but you got even more
fans or more rabid fans maybe in the
chat there how crazy wasn't there his
support from your stream today it was
crazy we got a lot of chickens in the in
the chats people just just getting white
like making pundit mode Young's I think
that's how you call it
shotgun in Williams when when I went in
there when Maxine won the game I said
say lass
everyone went wild I saw the Chad just
exploding so the chat ofin goes white I
think it was a chicken green beans
Maxime you've been talking a lot about
you know the frame the mindset of just
feeling fresh and feeling in good shape
and and we're talking about what it
takes to get there but what are your
peers there in fact your opponent of
yesterday Wang Hao said he thought you
you seemed tired at the board was that
maybe just the result of of having
played three days in a row and getting
ready for the rest day I'm gonna keep
talking as if you're here and that you
can hear my question every time you get
any talks how'd you deal with feeling
tired very tired streams we say Silla
has but this was a sailor Danny so I was
not feeling very tired though but I
don't know any of Maxine's mana reason I
haven't practice impersonating him I can
get my game on if you want sorry I think
you're back Maxine were you feeling
tired was the rest they needed to
Camille's yesterday oh dear God
this is a practical joke I don't need to
be here yes you want to get Ricky to
just say so I'm having the best time
I've had sorry guys
are you guys so sorry sorry the
questions yes I heard your question
oh yeah my game against one girl was a
very bad one and stopped moving Danny
like an idiot it was game but maybe I
was feeling a bit less fresh in that
game but it's also because when you have
a difficult position it's it's harder to
to be up here and to be to show you no
signs of good shape but in general my
shape my shape is all right maybe I had
slept I had not slept in off before my
game against funk how this happens to me
sometimes but yeah here I'm just feeling
fine
well if you don't mind sharing you know
you had a rest day yesterday what is
arrest I really like when you're in the
midst of well maybe the most important
tournament of all the players lives so
were you actually able to relax I mean
it's tough times is situation too I mean
mostly relaxed I mean I'm not so I'm
doing so so prep work I mean I have to
do few things but most of the things I
did yesterday were not about chess
I'm afraid to ask any more questions
because every time I do things go bad
but Maxine I just want to say thank you
Kevin why don't you give why don't you
give your countrymen their the last
question Maxine thank you again for
joining us
go ahead Gavin thank you just a question
on the rest days how are you dealing
with the world situation now the
pandemic obviously are you like trying
not to read out all the news or how do
you deal with that mentally just to keep
I've just focused in the tournament no
I'm obviously reading season news on
another great and of course I'm taking
in the news from my family and my
friends and of things that everything's
alright where's I'm in France but of
course I know that whenever I go back to
France it's gonna be a very strange
feeling to be in lockdown and such but
it's not that bad when you can follow my
sympathy like Raph playing the county
lights believe me yes and when I come
back to France when we survive I'm
always sort of quarantine
I will base on to Amazon chests calm so
you you can follow yeah we've got some
tournaments running right now at chest
icon you can play safely from home so
yeah
well well we'll let you get to it Maxime
again I know you spent the time making
the rounds interviews on a number of
different shows so we really appreciate
you taking the time dude and best of
luck great win today and maybe we'll see
you again tomorrow Thank You Danny thank
you bye thank you Oh burps
well that's but certainly not least is
me I guess and well we have the schedule
to remind everybody what are your
tomorrow will be like you'll be right
here same time same place
chess comm /tv twitch youtube you name
it the chess will continue and Danny we
just saw Maxie rush Sheila Grove very
happy Frenchman and honestly it's great
exciting for him I know he's excited to
be there but it is really cool to see
the guy who's always wanted nothing more
than to be in the kins to show that he
can fight with the best of them see
himself proving himself right he's
staying I'm not here as just some
last-minute entry I was deserving to be
here and no matter how you slice it up
and he is proving that for sure
a lot of people felt that way I mean it
was a storyline that you know dominated
the headlines for a little while the
fact that he would would be kind of on
the outside looking in yet again and
life moved on Maxie moved on he was
getting rest we talked to him a lot you
and I both just you know and that he was
really taking time to disconnect and
unplug a vacation before getting back in
the saddle where he thought his next big
event to prepare for the big series
would be the Grantchester again and then
suddenly as we said destiny will not be
denied fate comes knocking
we're job off rightfully so it you know
expresses great concern over the Cova 19
kind of crisis we're all facing and and
you know the whole thing is just it's
it's very interesting is just
interesting is it I mean this whole this
is odd I mean none of us have faced
something like this in our lifetime as
far as what's happening around the world
right now this is something out of a
movie to a degree of pandemic that that
is shaking a lot of things to their
roots and and Maxine Bochy the Grove is
getting an opportunity in some ways here
that he didn't think was gonna happen
maybe that mindset of being fresh and
not having the nerves going in is
keeping heavenly can play even better I
think overall he's just playing great
chess for whatever reason you know and
we'll see if he continues to do it I've
had a great time again hosting the show
shout out to all of you that are still
with us we appreciate it the chest
outcome coverage continues tomorrow as
Grand Master Robin has already said so I
won't drag on to longer thank you Robert
or yet again another great day
down it to the team working hard behind
the scenes go read Peter doctor's news
reports and we shall see you tomorrow
for round eight of the 20 20 feet at
candidates
[Music]